GOOD AFTERNOON WILL START
THE SENATE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE MEETING. SEE I GOT TO
DO IT MYSELF TURN OFF ALL YOUR
CELL PHONES. AND. TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OUTSIDE. WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A FULL SLATE OF
SPEAKERS SO WE WANT TO GET
RIGHT THROUGH THE SAID IN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE FOR THE- STE OUR COMMITTEE.
THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING. ON SB ONE. THIS IS THE
ROAD REPAIR AND ACCOUNTABILITY
TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN. THE
LEGISLATION PROVIDED- OVER FIVE
AND A HALF BILLION ANNUALLY IN
NEW FUNDING. TO STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO REPAIR OUR BADLY
WORN TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE. NOW WITH THE
NEW FUNDING WE EXPECT TO SEE
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS. SO
WE'RE HAVING AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE YEAR THIS HEARING TO.
SINCE WE GET AN UPDATE ON SB
ONE AND. FIND OUT SO WHAT OUR
CURRENT STATUS IS. PART OF SB
ONCE ACCOUNTABILITY PROVISIONS
SP ONE HAD A BROAD. COALITION
OF SUPPORTERS PUTTING LABOR
INDUSTRY AND BUSINESS
ORGANIZATION WHO ARE CONVINCED
THAT THERE WAS A CLEAR NEED FOR
THE NEW FINDING. BUT THEY ALSO
WANTED ASSURANCES THAT THE
FUNDS WOULD BE SPENT WISELY AND
CONSISTENTLY WITH SP ONE SO
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR TODAY ABOUT
HOW WE'RE DOING. LEARN ABOUT
OUR PROGRESS ACHIEVING
PERFORMANCE BENCHMARKS WHICH
WERE IN THIS BEING ONE. AND
FIND OUT WHAT TAXPAYERS ARE
GETTING FURTHER SP ONE DOLLARS.
I AM REALLY PLEASED TO HAVE ALL
THE SPEAKERS SO ALL ALL CUT MY
REMARKS SHORT NASCENT EITHER A
COLLEAGUES HERE THEY HAVE ANY
COMMENTS- BEFORE WE CAN START
OR SHOULD WE GO RIGHT AHEAD IF
ANYBODY WANT TO MAKE ANY.
COMMENTS THE MIX OF. OKAY THANK
YOU A FIRST- GROUP OF THE
RESPECTED INDIVIDUALS ARE STATE
AGENCIES WE HAVE- CALIFORNIA
STATE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY
SECRETARY DAVID KIM TOOK SO
MUCH EMOTION A CAN OF DIRECTOR
OF CALTRANS ARE TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSIONER- MITCH MITCHELL
WEISS IS- OUR NEW EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. AND ARE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT TRANSPORTATION
AUDITOR. IN THE INDEPENDENT
AUDITOR AROUND A CROWD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S OFFICE SO WE'LL BEGIN
WITH THIS GROUP AND I SUPPOSE
DAVID KIM. I'LL TURN OVER YOU
AS SECRETARY CAMP. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CHAIRMAN BILL AND
SENATORS ARE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOUR
COMMITTEE ON THE CONTINUED
PROGRESS. OF IMPLEMENTING JUST
BE ONE THE ROAD REPAIR AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. LET ME START BY
SAYING THAT WE ARE RELENTLESSLY
FOR- EXECUTING SB ONE PROGRAMS
AND PROJECT DELIVERY. AS A
RELATIVE NEWCOMER TO THIS
POSITION THIS IS FRONT AND
CENTER FOR ME AND THE ENTIRE
CAST A TEAM. AND AS WE WILL
SHARE WITH YOU TODAY. WE ARE
FOCUSED ON THE FOLLOWING KEY
AREAS. IMPROVING STATE OF GOOD
REPAIR. MAXIMIZE EFFICIENCIES.
DELIVERING ALL THE PROMISES OF
SB ONE. AS YOU KNOW THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
INCLUDES INVESTMENTS IN
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
AS WELL AS EFFORTS TO COMBAT
CLIMATE CHANGE. THE BUDGET
INCLUDES FIVE POINT FOUR
BILLION IN VOTER APPROVED SB
ONE FUNDS. DIVIDED BETWEEN
STATE AND LOCAL INVESTMENTS IN
THE FOLLOWING MANNER. THREE
POINT FIVE BILLION FOR EXISTING
INVESTMENT AND ROAD REPAIR
REHABILITATION AND MAINTENANCE
AND ONE POINT NINE BILLION FOR
TRANSIT RAIL. TRADE CORRIDOR
ENHANCEMENTS CONGESTION
SOLUTIONS ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
AND OTHER PROJECTS. THE
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES HAVE FOR
THE NEARLY EIGHT THOUSAND
PROJECTS STATEWIDE AND CREATED
THOUSANDS OF NEW JOBS. ALSO 60%
OF CARPENTRY PROCEEDS ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION ARE COMMITTED TO
HIGH SPEED RAIL TRANSIT AND
INTERCITY RAIL LOW CARBON
TRANSIT OPERATIONS AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES.
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENT IS
CRITICAL TO ACHIEVING MANY THE
PRIORITIES REFLECTED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDING
MAINTAINING INFRASTRUCTURE
CLIMATE RESILIENCY CREATING
JOBS. CONSTRUCTING ECONOMY AND
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS. BUT
LET ME BE CLEAR. SB ONE FUNDS
ARE PROTECTED AND LOCKED IN. WE
ARE HONORING THE WILL OF THE
VOTERS AND THESE FUNDS ARE
BEING USED FOR THEIR INTENDED
PURPOSE. WITH THE AVAILABLE
FUNDING CALTRANS EXPECTS THAT
THE OVERALL CONDITION OF
PRIMARY ASSET CLASSES CLASSES
PAVEMENT BRIDGES CULVERTS AND
TRANSPORTATION MANAGEMENT
SYSTEMS. WILL IMPROVE OVER THE
NEXT TEN YEARS. WITH ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FROM SB ONE ANNUAL
FUNDING RELATIVE TO NEED HAS
MORE THAN DOUBLED. MINUTES
PROGRAMS FOCUSED ON PAVEMENT
BRIDGES AND TUNNELS DRAINAGE
SYSTEMS AND TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
PROJECTS OUR WILL RESOURCE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I FIRMLY
BELIEVE THAT CALTRANS IS ON
TRACK TO MEET SB ONE TARGETS BY
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN. THIS
INCLUDES 90% OF PAVEMENT AND
GOOD OR FAIR ONDITION. 90% OF
CULVERTS IN GOOD FOR CONDITION.
90% OF TRANSPORTATION
MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS IN GOOD
CONDITION. AND FIXING AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED BRIDGES.
DURING THE FIRST TWO YEARS OF
SB ONE FROM AUGUST TWNTY
SEVENTEEN TILL DECEMBER TWENTY
NINETEEN. APPROXIMATELY FOUR
POINT FOUR BILLIONHAS BEEN
ALLOCATED STATEWIDE FROM THE
MANY PROGRAMS CREATED BY SB ONE.
THESE DOLLARS HAVE FUNDED OR
EXPENDED ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE CAPITAL AND
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS- LED BY
CALTRANS AND WE ANTICIPATE
800-880-0408 MORE PROJECTS WILL
BE FUNDED. IN VARIOUS PHASES
THIS YEAR. ALSO I'D LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT SB ONE HAS MADE
A MEANINGFUL IMPACT ON TRANSIT.
AND RAIL PROJECTS STATEWIDE
WITH A LONG TERM COMMITMENT A
FUNDING FROM THE TRANSIT AND
INNER CITY CAPITAL PROGRAM.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS T. I. R. C.
P. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY AWARDED
FOUR POINT THREE BILLION. TO
PROJECTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
FUNDED BY BOTH SP ONE. AND THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND.
THE PROGRAM HAS MADE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
TRANSFORMATIVE TRANSIT AND REAL
PROJECTS ALL OVER CALIFORNIA.
IN THE BAY AREA THESE INCLUDE
THE BAR EXTENSION TO SAN JOSE
CALTRAIN ELECTRIFICATION AND
FLEET EXPANSION AND EXPANSION
OF SMART TO LARKSPUR IN WINTER.
WE'VE ALSO INVESTED IN ZERO
MISSION BUS SERVICE BETWEEN
SACRAMENTO AND READING.
EXPANSION OF STOCK OR TEA LIGHT
RAIL SERVICE TO FOLSOM. VALLEY
REAL INVESTMENT IN PEACE AND
THE AMTRAK SN WALKING REAL
SERVICE. AND ZERO EMISSION
BUSES IN FRESNO ANTELOPE VALLEY
AND SANTA BARBARA. IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE MADE KEY
INVESTMENTS IN THE ORANGE
COUNTY STREET CAR THE REDLANDS
RAIL PROJECT. LA METRO LA DASH
METROLINK AND LOS AND SERVICE
EXPANSION AND THE SAN DIEGO
TROLLEY AND BUS SYSTEM. AND NOW
IN TWENTY TWENTY WE ARE
PREPARED TO MAKE A NEW ROUND OF
T. I. R. C. P. PROJECT WORKS BY
APRIL FIRST. ADDING NEW
PROJECTS TO THE FIVE POINT
THREE BILLION THAT HAS ALREADY
BEEN AWARDED. OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS. SB ONE FUNDING HAS
ALLOWED THE STATE TO EXPAND ITS
PARTNERSHIPS WITH LOCAL
AGENCIES. IN THE VETTING THESE
CRITICAL TRANSIT. AND REAL
PROJECTS ALL OVER CALIFORNIA.
BUT ALSO LIKE TO BRIEFLY TOUCH
UPON THE GOVERNOR'S CLIMATE
CHANGE EXECUTIVE ORDER IN
NINETEEN NINETEEN WHICH WAS
UNVEILED THIS PAST SEPTEMBER.
FIRST LET'S START WITH THE BIG
PICTURE. THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE ARE ALL AROUND US WE ARE
SEEING IT DAILY. EXTREME
WEATHER PATTERNS MORE WILD
FIRES INCLUDING JUST RECENTLY
MORE FLOODING MORE INTENSE HEAT
AND COLD. THIS IS GOING TO
REQUIRE CHANGES IN TERMS OF HOW
WE LIVE OUR LIVES AND WE NEED
TO KEEP AN EYE ON WHAT IT WILL
TAKE TO MITIGATE CLIMATE
CHANGE. AND ADAPT TO IT.
BECAUSE IF WE FAIL TO TAKE
STEPS NOW. FUTURE GENERATIONS
OUR KIDS AND GRANDKIDS. WILL
PAY THE PRICE. ALSO YOU KNOW
THE DATA POINT. 40%OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS COME
FROM THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
SO ALL OF US WHO WORK IN
TRANSPORTATION. HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY. TO BE PART
SOLUTION. BUT HAVING SAID THAT.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
MAINTAINING THE CONDITION OF
OUR HIGHWAYS ROADS AND BRIDGES
IS OF THE UTMOST IMPORTANCE TO
GOVERNOR SOME. AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER DOES NOT CHANGE YOUR
EMPHASIS ON FIX IT FIRST. THAT
WILL CONTINUE. THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER ALSO DOES NOT SUPERSEDE
STATE LAW. NOR DOES IT
SUPERSEDE ARTICLE NINETEEN OF
THE CONSTITUTION. SB ONE FUNDS
ARE PROTECTED IN LOCKED IN. AND
WE ARE HONORING THE WILL OF THE
VOTERS THESE FUNDS ARE BEING
USED FOR THEIR INTENDED PURPOSE.
WHILE PRIORITIZING FIX IT FIRST
WE ALSO NEED TO LOOK FOR
OPPORTUNITIES TO DELIVER
PROJECTS THAT HELP. TACKLE
CONGESTION BY ENCOURAGING MORE
WALKING. BIKING AND TRANSIT USE.
WE WILL ALSO CONSIDER PROJECTS
THAT SUPPORT SUSTAINABLE FREE
AND PROMOTE GREATER ADOPTION OF
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES. AND WE
ALSO NEED TO LOOK AT PROJECTS
THAT MAKE OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
MORE RESILIENT TO THE IMPACTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE. ALL THESE
PROJECTS ARE CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE
WITHIN THE VARIOUS SB ONE
PROGRAMS. WERE TAKING A
STRATEGIC APPROACH TO ENSURE
THAT OUR PLANNING. PROGRAMMING
AND PROJECT DELIVERY FUNCTIONS
INCLUDE SCOPING FUNDING AND
BUILDING PROJECTS THAT WILL
MEET THE STATE'S AMBITIOUS
CLIMATE GOALS. AS WELL AS SB
ONCE FIXIT FIRST PERFORMANCE
TARGETS FOR PAVEMENT. BRIDGES
DRAINAGE AND TRANSPORTATION
MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS. I ALSO WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER IS THE BEGINNING OF THE
CONVERSATION NOT THE END. SO IN
TERMS OF NEXT STEPS MY AGENCY
WILL DEVELOP AN IMPLEMENTATION
ACTION PLAN AND IT WILL BE
INFORMED BY INPUT AND
COLLABORATION FROM THE PUBLIC.
AND MEMBERS A LEGISLATURE ALL
OF YOU. THIS WILL BE DONE IN
CLOSE PARTNERSHIP WITH A BROAD
ARRAY OF TRANSPORTATION
STAKEHOLDERS. AND SO AS WE
EMBARK ON THIS EFFORT WE WILL
KEEP YOU AND YOUR STAFF
INFORMED OF NEW DEVELOPMENTS.
IN THE WEEKS AND MONTHS AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR
BEFORE YOU TODAY. CALTRANS
DIRECTOR TALKS ON SHARK IN
WILSHIRE REVIEW MORE DETAILS.
ON HOW THE DEPARTMENT IS
IMPLEMENTING SB ONE PROGRAMS.
REALIZING EFFICIENCIES.
ENGAGING SMALL AND
DISADVANTAGED BUSINESSES THANKS
TO THE CONCERT WILL
AUGMENTATION. IN STATE
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING FROM SB
ONE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SECRETARY- TOOK SOME SHOCKING
INNER ARE CALTRANS DIRECTOR OF
THE FLOOR. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN. AND
SENATORS. MY NAME IS TALK SO
MUCH SHOCK IN DIRECTOR OF
CALTRANS. I'M PLEASED TO BE
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT OUR
PROGRESS THANKS TO THE PASSAGE
OF SB ONE. SB ONE AUGMENTS THE
STATE'S TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
PROVIDING ABOUT FIVE POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
BETWEEN STATE AND LOCAL
INVESTMENTS. SINCE THE PASSAGE
OF SB ONE CALTRANS AND OUR
PARTNERS HAVE COMPLETED THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO PROJECTS.
AND WE HAVE EIGHT HUNDRED AND
FORTY EIGHT MORE PROJECTS IN
THE WORKS ON A HIGHWAY
MAINTENANCE AND COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROGRAMS. WE CONTINUE TO
PRIORITIZE OUR FOUR CORE
ASSETS. PAVEMENT BRIDGES
COVERTS AND DRAINAGE SYSTEMS
AND TECHNOLOGY THAT KEEPS
TRAFFIC SYSTEM FLOWING.
CALTRANS CONTINUES TO
INCORPORATE COMPLETE STREETS
ELEMENTS WERE COST EFFECTIVE
AND APPROPRIATE AND CLIMATE
RESIDENT RESILIENCY FEATURES
INTO OUR PROJECTS CONSISTENT
WITH THE GUARANTEES OF ARTICLE
NINETEEN OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION. THE FUNDING WILL
CONTINUE TO BE SPENT EXACTLY US
ATTENDED BY SB ONE AN ARTICLE
NINETEEN. OUR FIX IT FIRST
APPROACH MUST CONTINUE. THIS IS
THE THIRD YEAR OF SB ONE AND
WE'RE ENTERING A NEW PHASE
WHERE MOVING MORE PROJECTS FOR
TO CONSTRUCTION AND SEEN
GREATER PROGRESS THIS YEAR. I
AM PLEASED TO TELL YOU. THAT
ALL A PROPOSED TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY STATE HIGHWAY OPERATIONS
IN PROTECTION PROGRAM ALSO
KNOWN AS THE SHOP. REPRESENTS
THE SINGLE LARGEST YEAR FUNDING
THAT WE'VE SEEN IN RECENT
HISTORY THANKS TO SB ONE. OUR
MOST RECENT PERFORMANCE
BENCHMARK REPORT SHOWS THAT
CALTRANS IS ON TRACK TO EXCEED
SB ONE PERFORMANCE TARGETS BY
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN FOR
PAVEMENT BRIDGES AND CULVERTS.
AS OF JUNE TWENTY NINETEEN WE
HAVE COMPLETED MORE PROJECTS
REHABILITATING MORE THAN THIRTY
EIGHT HUNDRED LANE MILES OF
PAVEMENT AND FIXING MORE THAN
NINETEEN OF FIXING THE PROBLEM.
APPROXIMATELY NINETEEN BRIDGES.
IN THE COMING STATE HOW WE
OPERATIONS AND PROTECTION
PROGRAM CALTRANS WILL FIX AN
ADDITIONAL. FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED
LANE MILES OF PAVEMENT TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY BRIDGES.
FOUR THOUSAND. RATED SYSTEMS
AND MORE THAN THIRTY FOUR
HUNDRED CONGESTION REDUCING
TRAFFIC MANAGEMENT ELEMENTS.
LET ME JUST HIGHLIGHT SOME OF
THE PROJECTS THIS FUNDING IS
NOW MAKING POSSIBLE. SB ONE IS
CONTRIBUTING TO PAVEMENT
REHABILITATION PROJECTS ACROSS
THE STATE INCLUDING. TO PAY MY
PROJECTS WITH A TOTAL OF EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS ON HOW WE
SEVENTEEN IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
THREE PROJECTS TOTALLING ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS ON INTERSTATE FIFTEEN
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY. EIGHT ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR PROJECT ON HOW WE SIXTY
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY. TWO
PROJECTS TOTALING SIXTY NINE
MILLION ON INTERSTATE EIGHTY IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY. A SEVENTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR PROJECT ON
INTERSTATE SIX OH FIVE IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. AND SB ONES ARE
ALSO GOING TO THREE BRIDGE
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS WITH A
TOTAL WITH A TOTAL OF THIRTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS ON HOW WE
TWENTY NINES IN NAPA COUNTY. SB
ONE IS ALSO FORMING PART OF A
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE
MILLION DOLLAR BRIDGE AND
PAVEMENT MAINTENANCE PROJECT ON
HOW WE WANT TO ONE. IN HUMBOLDT
COUNTY. SB ONE FUNDS ARE ALSO
CONTRIBUTING TO A THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR PROJECT FOUR
EIGHT MILE CARPOOL LANE OR NOT
BECAUSE CORD- ON INTERSTATE
FIVE IN SAN DIEGO. I COULD O
ON. BUT I THINK YOU GET A SENSE
OF THE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT SB
ONE IS MAKING ACROSS OUR STATE.
NOW TO EFFICIENCIES SB ONE ALSO
REQUIRES THE CALTRANS IDENTIFY
AND IMPLEMENT EFFICIENCIES WITH
THE LOOK WITH THE GOAL OF
GENERATING AT LEAST ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN SAVINGS EACH
YEAR. FOR THE SECOND YEAR IN A
ROW CALTRANS WAS ABLE TO EXCEED
DISCO SAVING MORE THAN DOUBLE
THE ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
MARK IN THE LAST FISCAL YEAR.
THE SAVINGS ALLOW FOR
ADDITIONAL REPAIR AND
MAINTENANCE OF A HIGHWAYS AND
BRIDGES ACROSS THE STATE. TO
ACHIEVE THESE EFFICIENCIES
CALTRANS IS FOCUSED ON THREE
AREAS PROCESS IMPROVEMENT NEW
TECHNOLOGY AND INNOVATIVE TOOLS.
WE APPRECIATE THE OPTIONS THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE'S TAKEN TO
GIVE US THESE EFFICIENCIES.
CALTRANS WAS THE FOR STATE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION IN
THE COUNTRY. TO BE A SIGN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
RESPONSIBILITY TO REVIEW
PROJECTS UNDER NEPA OR NATIONAL
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY ACT WE
RECOGNIZE THE SUPPORT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PROVIDED TO
PERMANENTLY EXTEND THE
AUTHORITY THAT WAS GIVEN TO US.
THIS ASSIGNMENT OF AUTHORITY
HAS ACHIEVED SIGNIFICANT TIME
SAVINGS BY ALLOWING CALTRANS TO
COMPLETE ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENTS MORE THAN A YEAR
EARLIER ON AVERAGE. SHORTENING
THE TIME THAT ALLOWS FOR
CONSTRUCTION TO BEGIN AND
REDUCING CONSTRUCTION CALLS
ULTIMATELY OVERALL. CALTRANS
HAS ALSO BEEN PILOTING AN
INNOVATIVE METHOD METHOD OF
PROJECT DELIVERY KNOWN AS
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER GENERAL
CONTRACTOR ALSO KNOWN AS C. M.
G. C. THIS CONTRACTING TWO
ALLOWS CALTRANS TO HIRE A
CONTRACTOR DURING THE DESIGN
PROCESS PROVIDING VALUABLE
INPUT THAT CAN REDUCE COSTS.
AND CHANGE ORDERS AND BETTER
MANAGE RISK THAT WE MAY HAVE.
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE
RECOGNIZED THE POTENTIAL OF
THIS TOO AND PROVIDED CALTRANS
WITH PERMANENT CNG C. AUTHORITY.
THIS METHOD ALLOWS CALTRANS TO
THIS METHOD ALLOWED CALTRANS TO
SAY MORE THAN FOURTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS ON TWO PROJECTS JUST
LAST YEAR. SB ONE ALSO CREATED
THE INNOVATIVE ADVANCE
MITIGATION PROGRAM WHAT FOUR
YEARS OF INITIAL FUNDING THAT
WILL AMOUNT TO A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS AND A
REVOLVING ACCOUNT BY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THIS PROGRAM IS A
NEW TYPE OF BUSINESS PRACTICE
DOUBT THAT WILL FUND THE
CREATION AND PURCHASE OF
MITIGATION CREDITS TO BE USED
ON TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS. THE
PROJECTS WILL REIMBURSE THE
ADVANCED MEDICATION ACCOUNT FOR
THE USE OF CREDITS CREATING A
MORE SUSTAINABLE FUNDING LOOP
FOR ADVANCED MEDICATION
ACTIVITIES. WE RELEASED
GUIDELINES FOR THE PROGRAM LAST
YEAR AND ON SCHEDULE TO FUND
THE FIRST PROJECTS IN THIS
PROGRAM AND A PROGRAM THIS
SUMMER. THE NEW PROGRAM IS
MODELED ON A PILOT CONDUCTED IN
THE SHOP THAT HAS ALREADY
BENEFITING SB ONE PROJECTS.
CALTRANS AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY ARE
ALSO PART OF AB TWELVE EIGHTY
TWO PERMITTING TASK FORCE WHICH
IS EVALUATING WAYS TO
STREAMLINE PERMITTING IN
COLLABORATION WITH RESOURCE
AGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE. THE
STREAMLINED PERMITTING IS
EXPECTED TO BENEFIT OUR ABILITY
TO PROVIDE ENVIRONMENTAL
MITIGATION FOR TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS. THIS TASK FORCE WERE
RELEASED A REPORT SOON
OUTLINING OUR STRATEGIES ON THE
WAY TO CREATE PERMITTING
EFFICIENCIES AND OUR AND OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW THE FORD
ADVANCE THIS EFFORT. ON THE
RESEARCH FRONT CALTRANS IS
WORKING TO DEVELOP TEST AND
EVALUATE TRANSPORTATION
INNOVATIONS THAT WILL ENABLE
THE STATE TO IN A IMPROVE IN
MANY IN MANY AREAS FOR EXAMPLE
CALTRANS PAVEMENT RESEARCH
PROGRAM IS WORKING ON NEW AND
INNOVATIVE WAYS TO INCORPORATE
RECYCLED MATERIAL AND TO
PAVEMENT AND TO DEVELOP LONG
LASTING PAYMENT SOLUTIONS THAT
A KID CAN ACHIEVE IGNIFICANT
COST SAVINGS AND ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS. NOT TO SMALL BUSINESS
AND DISADVANTAGED BUSINESS
CONTRACTING. CALTRANS ALSO
CONTINUES TO ADVANCE OUR
EFFORTS TO ENGAGE SMALL
BUSINESSES DISADVANTAGED
BUSINESSES INCLUDING VETERAN
WOMEN AND MINORITY OWNED FIRMS
TO REACH DIVERSE BUSINESSES
THAT HAVE NEVER CONTRACTED WITH
CALTRANS. DURING THE LAST
FISCAL YEAR CALTRANS WAS
CALTRANS AWARDED MORE THAN ONE
BILLION DOLLARS TO SMALL
BUSINESSES DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESSES AND PRIZES AND
DISADVANTAGED BUSINESS
ENTERPRISES. CALTRANS SMALL
BUSINESS CONTRACTING IS
EXPANDING I ALMOST DOUBLE THE
RATE OF OUR OVERALL CONTRACT.
WE EXPECT TO SEE THE FULL
IMPACT OF SB ONE AND RELATED
INCREASES FOR SMALL BUSINESS
CONTRACTING BY TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. TO ACHIEVE THIS GROW. WE
HAVE PUT ON OVER THREE HUNDRED
EVENTS IN THE LAST TWO YEARS TO
REACH SMALL BUSINESSES AND
DIVERSE GROUPS TO ENCOURAGE
PARTICIPATION AND CALTRANS
CONTRACTS ARE REGIONAL SMALL
BUSINESS COUNCIL CONTINUES TO
ENGAGE WITH ETHNIC SPECIFIC
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE TO PROVIDE NETWORKING
AND TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES. TO
SMALL BUSINESS. CALTRANS HAS
ALSO BEEN WORKING TO INFORM AND
EDUCATE SMALL BUSINESSES
INCLUDING VETERAN WOMEN OR
MINORITY OWNED FIRMS THROUGH
ONE HUNDRED TARGETED
ADVERTISEMENTS AND DOZENS OF
PUBLICATIONS. WOULD COMBINE
WEEKLY READERSHIP OF MORE THAN
ONE MILLION PEOPLE. THESE
EFFORTS ARE BRINGING THE
POSITIVE IMPACTS OF SB ONE AND
STATE CONTRACTING TO MORE
CALIFORNIANS THAN EVER BEFORE.
AND WE CONTINUE TO EXPAND
OPPORTUNITIES TO WORK WITH
CALTRANS. I AM ALSO PROUD TO
REPORT THAT WE HAVE RE BRANDED
OUR OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY AS THE
OFFICE OF CIVIL RIGHTS. THIS
RETURN THREE OFFICES ORIGINAL
NAME RECOGNIZES CALTRANS
COMMITMENT TO ADVANCE IN EQUITY
AND CONTRACTED. WE RECOGNIZE
THAT SB ONE OFFERS GREAT
OPPORTUNITIES TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
VETERANS WOMEN AND OTHER
MINORITY GROUPS WHO'VE
HISTORICALLY FACED
DISADVANTAGES. IN CLOSING I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
INVESTMENT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
MADE ON SB ONE THROUGH SB ONE.
TO ACHIEVE THE VISION OF SB ONE
AND MY OVERALL GOAL FOR
CALTRANS WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
FIVE PRIORITIES THAT WE WILL BE
WORKING ON MOVING FORWARD.
SAFETY ENGAGEMENT. EFFICIENCIES
MULTIMODALITY AND INNOVATION.
MY NUMBER ONE PRIORITY IS
SAFETY AND THAT'S THE NUMBER
ONE PRIORITY FOR THE DEPARTMENT
AS WELL WE NEED A
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM THAT IS
SAFE FOR ALL USERS. AND OUR
WORKERS WOULD INCREASE
INVESTMENTS FROM SB ONE WERE
INVESTING IN MORSE SAFETY
IMPROVEMENTS WHILE ALSO
DOUBLING THE NUMBER OF HOW WE
WORK CELLS. SO IT'S IMPORTANT
IT'S MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER
TO BE WORKS ON ALERT. CALTRANS
SO. UP CALTRANS MUST ALSO WORK
TO BUILD BETTER PARTNERSHIPS
AND IMPROVE OUR ENGAGEMENT.
INCLUDING WITH THOSE WHO
HISTORICALLY HAVE NOT HAD A
VOICE IN THE PROCESS WE CAN BE
MORE EFFECTIVE IN DELIVERING
PROJECTS AND CREATING LIVABLE
COMMUNITIES IF WE BRING MORE
VOICES INTO THE CONVERSATION.
AS A DEPARTMENT WE NEED TO
IMPLEMENT EFFICIENCIES TO
DELIVER ON OUR COMMITMENTS.
EFFICIENCIES MAKE THE MOST OF
OUR RESOURCES TO REPAIR AND
MAINTAIN THE SYSTEM MORE
EFFECTIVELY AS HIGHLIGHTED BY
SB ONE. WE ALSO NEED TO BE
FLEXIBLE AND MULTI MODAL.
CALIFORNIA CAN'T JUST BUILD ITS
WAY OUT OF CONGESTION. WE HAVE
TO LOOK AT IMPROVING ALL MODES
OF TRANSPORTATION AS WE
IMPLEMENT PROJECTS TO GIVE
CALIFORNIANS OPTIONS TO MEET
THEIR NEEDS. FINALLY WE NEED TO
BE INNOVATIVE AND CREATIVE AND
OUR APPROACH TO SOLVING
PROBLEMS WE NEED TRANSFORMATIVE
IDEAS TO ACHIEVE ASPIRATIONAL
GOALS LIKE REDUCING OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS BY 40%
BY TWENTY THIRTY AND REACHING
ZERO RELATE RELATED TRAFFIC
FATALITIES AS WELL. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
CALTRANS ACHIEVEMENTS AND TO
PRESENT THE GREAT PROGRESS THAT
SB ONE HAS MADE POSSIBLE. I'M
HAPPY TO RESPOND TO QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE AFTER THE REST OF
MY COLLEAGUES SPEAK ON THE
PANEL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DIRECTOR WILL TURN OVER TO
THEIR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION- MITCHELL WISE AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR POINT.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU I'M A
PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY TO
PROVIDE. MEETING IN BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE. IN MY NEW CAPACITY
IT IS YES THEY WILL. WELCOME
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO SOME
SLIPPAGE QUESTIONS. I'M GOING
TO BE HERE TODAY READY FOR IT.
I AM PLEASED TO BE HERE TO
PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON SB ONE
IMPLEMENTATION LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR PELL AND THE COMMITTEE
FOR INVITING US TO THIS HEARING.
BOBBI GIVE YOU A BRIEF OVERVIEW
OF THE COMMISSION'S WORK AN
UPDATE ON THE COMMISSION'S
IMPLEMENTATION OF THREE NEW
PROGRAMS CREATED BY SB ONE. AND
I'LL TALK ABOUT WHAT LIES AHEAD
FOR THOSE PROGRAMS. AS
BACKGROUND THE COMMISSION IS
INDEPENDENT BODY THAT A
STATUTORILY RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROGRAMMING IN ALLOCATED
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF HIGHWAY
PASSENGER RAIL TRANSIT AN
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. WHAT
THAT MEANS IS THAT THE
COMMISSION THREE PUBLIC AND
OPEN PROCESS ESTABLISHES THE
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES THAT
GUIDE THE DEDICATION OF FUNDS
TO TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS IN STATUTE AND THE
STATE CONSTITUTION. THE
COMMISSION THAT OVERSEES THE
DELIVERY OF THESE PROJECTS BY
CALTRANS AND LOCAL AND REGIONAL
AGENCIES TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE DELIVERED ON TIME AND
WITHIN THE APPROVED BUDGET AND
SCOPE. THE COMMISSION CONDUCTS
ITS BUSINESS AT PUBLIC MEETINGS
OPEN TO ALL STAKEHOLDERS AND
THE PUBLIC. THE COMMISSION ALSO
HOLDS DOZENS OF WORKSHOPS
ANNUALLY TO SOLICIT INPUT FROM
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE PUBLIC ON
ITS POLICIES AND PROCESSES. I
NOW LIKE TO TURN TO THE
COMMISSION'S THREE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THREE NEW
PROGRAMS CREATED BY SB ONE.
THESE ARE THE SOLUTION FOR
CONGESTED CORRIDORS PROGRAM
WHICH FUNDS PROJECTS DESIGNED
TO REDUCE CONGESTION AND HIGHLY
TRAVELED AND HIGHLY CONGESTED
CORRIDORS TO PERFORMANCE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT BALANCE
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENTS
COMMUNITY IMPACTS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS. THE
LOCAL PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM WHICH
PROVIDES FUNDING TO CITIES
COUNTIES DISTRICTS AND REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES IN
WHICH VOTERS HAVE APPROVED
TAXES OR FEES SOLELY DEDICATED
TO TRANSPORTATION OR THAT HAVE
ENACTED TAXES OR FEES SOLELY
DEDICATED TO TRANSPORTATION.
AND THE TREE COURT OR ENHANCE
PROGRAM WHICH FUNDS
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS ON
FEDERALLY DESIGNATED TRADE
CORRIDORS OR LONG OTHER
QUARTERS THAT HAVE A HIGH
VOLUME OF FREIGHT MOVEMENT.
IMMEDIATELY AFTER SB ONE PASSED
IN APRIL TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
COMMISSION BEGAN HOLDING
WORKSHOPS TO DEVELOP GUIDELINES
FOR THESE PROGRAMS AND CONTINUE
TO CONTINUE TO DO SO THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR. STARTING IN MAY
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE COMMISSION
BEGAN ADOPTING PROGRAMS ARE
PROJECTS. TO DATE THE
COMMISSION HAS PROGRAM THE
FOLLOWING SB ONE FUNDS FOR
THESE PROGRAMS. ONE BILLION
DOLLARS OVER FOUR YEARS FOR
NINE PROJECTS IN THE SOLUTION
COULD FOR SOLUTIONS FOR
CONGESTED CORRIDORS PROGRAM ONE
AN EXAMPLE OF A PROJECT FUNDED
FROM THIS PROGRAM IS THAT SAN
DIEGO NORTH COAST QUARTER
PROGRAM WHICH WILL BILL TWENTY
SIX MILES A MANAGE LANES ONE
POINT THREE MILES. BICYCLE
PEDESTRIAN FACILITIES THREE
AUXILIARY LANES AND TWENTY
SMART SIGNAL UPGRADES THIS
PROJECT IS RECEIVING NEARLY TWO
HUNDRED MILLION SB ONE FUNDS.
THE COMMISSION IS PROGRAM ONE
POINT FOUR BILLION OVER THREE
FISCAL YEARS FOR TWENTY
PROJECTS IN THE TRADE CORD OR
ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM. AN EXAMPLE
OF A PROJECT FUNDED FROM THIS
PROGRAM IS THE FREIGHT
INTELLIGENT TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM PROJECT IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY. THIS PROJECT IS
RECEIVING TWELVE AND A HALF
MILLION IN SB ONE FUNDS TO
IMPROVE OPERATIONS AND ESTIMATE
FISSION CITY. ROAD RACE
ROADWAYS ACCESSING THE PORT OF
OAKLAND. FINALLY THE COMMISSION
IS PROGRAMMED SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OVER THREE
FISCAL YEARS. FOR OVER A
HUNDRED PROJECTS IN THE LOCAL
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM. AN EXAMPLE
OF A PROJECT FUNDED IN PART IN
THIS PROGRAM. IS THAT REDLANDS
PASSENGER RAIL PROJECT WHICH
WILL CONSTRUCT NINE MILES OF
RAIL TRACK AND FIVE NEW TRANSIT
STATIONS IN SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY. THE PROJECT IS
RECEIVING SEVENTEEN MILLION
FROM THE LOCALS PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM. AND ALSO SIXTY FIVE
MILLION FROM THAT SOLUTIONS FOR
CONGESTED CORRIDOR PROGRAM.
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF HOW WE
HAVE SUCCESSFULLY LEVERAGED
FUNDS ACROSS OUR PROGRAMS.
AFTER ADOPTING THESE PROGRAMS
ARE PROJECTS THE COMMISSION
BEGAN APPROVING PROJECT
ALLOCATIONS. AN ALLOCATION
AUTHORIZES AN AGENCY TO BEGIN
SPENDING THE FUNDS. DURING
FISCAL YEAR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
THE COMMISSION APPROVED NEARLY
ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
ALLOCATIONS FOR THESE PROGRAMS
FOR SEVENTY TWO PROJECTS ARE
PROJECTS SEGMENTS. THAT ACTUAL
SPENDING ON THESE PROJECTS IS
WELL UNDER WAY AT THE
REIMBURSEMENTS HAVE AMOUNTED TO
MORE THAN A TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS AN ACTUAL EXPENDITURES
ARE LIKELY MUCH HIGHER THAN
THAT. THEY HAVE YET BEEN BILL
TO CALTRANS. ALL TOGETHER THE
PROJECTS TO DATE FOR THESE
THREE PROGRAMS RESULTED IN
HUNDREDS OF MILES OF LOCAL ROAD
REHABILITATION. NEW HIGH
OCCUPANCY VEHICLE LANES AND NEW
HOV LOOK INTO HOT LANES NEW
BICYCLE LANES AS WELL AS DOZENS
OF MILES OF NEW RAIL TRACK AND
YOU TRANSIT STATIONS. ONCE
THESE PROJECTS ARE COMPLETE
THEY WILL IMPROVE THE QUALITY
OF LIFE FOR PEOPLE ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BY SAVING
TIME IMPROVING AIR QUALITY.
BEFORE I CLOSE I WANT TO TALK
BRIEFLY ABOUT WHAT LIES AHEAD
FOR THESE PROGRAMS. COMMISSION
STAFF HAVE SPENT THE LAST YEAR
ENGAGING WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND
THE PUBLIC TO DEVELOP UPDATED
GUIDELINES FOR THE NEXT CYCLE
OF FUNDING FOR EACH OF THESE
THREE PROGRAMS. THE COMMISSION
ADOPTED NEW GUIDELINES AND
ISSUED A CALL FOR PROJECTS FOR
THE SOLUTION FOR CONGESTED
CORRIDOR PROGRAM. AT ITS
JANUARY MEETING WE EXPECT TO DO
THE SAME FOR THE LOCAL
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM ENTRY COURT
ANNOUNCEMENT PROGRAM. IN MARCH.
APPLICATIONS WILL BE DUE IN
JUNE AND THE COMMISSION EXPECTS
TO ADOPT NEW PROGRAMS A
PROJECTS BY DECEMBER. THAT
CONCLUDES MY TESTIMONY BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AFTER THE
PANEL'S COMPLETE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WILL NOW HEAR FROM
RHONDA CRAFT SHE'S THE- OF
OFFICE OF AUDITS AND
INVESTIGATIONS. WE CALL HER THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL. SO GENERAL
CRAFT YOU HAVE THE FLOOR. THANK
YOU KAREN BELL THAT WAS CREATED
BY UNDER SP ONE THE OFFICE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. I'LL BEGIN
WITH A BIT OF BACKGROUND IN
TERMS OF THE STRUCTURE OR
ORGANIZATION OF MY OFFICE THE
INDEPENDENT OFFICE OF AUDITS
AND INVESTIGATIONS OF
STRUCTURED INTO FIVE AREAS
WHICH A LINE. SOME OF THEM A
LINE WITH CALTRANS MAJOR
PROGRAM AREAS FOR EXAMPLE
FINANCING OPERATIONS PROJECT
DELIVERY PLANNING AND MODEL. IN
ADDITION MY OFFICE INCLUDES A
DIVERSITY AND SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM WHICH IS A
MANDATE OF SB ONE OF THREE THAT
REQUIRES THE INSPECTOR AND ALL
TO. PART IT'S TO INCREASE. IT'S
HIRING AND CONTRACTING
PRACTICES WE ALSO HAVE IN
INVESTIGATIONS AREA WHICH
INCLUDES AN ETHICS HOTLINE. THE
ETHICS HOTLINE IS A PHONE AND
INTERNET BASED MULTI LINGUAL
SERVICE FOR CALTRANS EMPLOYEES
AND THE PUBLIC TO REPORT
ALLEGATIONS OF FRAUD WASTE
ABUSE EMPLOYEE MISCONDUCT AND
OTHER ETHICS POLICY VIOLATIONS
ADDITIONALLY THE SERVICE
INCLUDES AN ASK ETHICS PHONE
NUMBER AND EMAIL ADDRESS ARE
AVAILABLE FOR CALTRANS
EMPLOYEES TO SEEK GUIDANCE AND
ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT SITUATION
SIR ISSUES IN THE WORKPLACE.
HE'S CALL CONCERNS. TURNING TO
OUR AUDITS IN FISCAL YEAR
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE OFFICE
COMPLETED A TOTAL OF SEVENTY
AUDITS INCLUDING PROGRAM. THAT
ALSO INCLUDE MANDATE IT OUT
IT'S REQUIRED BY FEDERAL AND
OUR STATE REGULATIONS
OPERATIONAL AUDITS BASED ON
RISK ASSESSMENTS AND OTHER
INTERNAL AUDIT SERVICES OR
SPECIAL REQUEST AUDITS. THEY
ALSO PERFORMED LOCAL AGENCY OUT
ITS THESE INVOLVE- A STORAGE
SHIP IN OVERSIGHT AGREEMENT
BETWEEN FEDERAL HIGHWAY SAFETY
ADMINISTRATION. AND CALTRANS
WHICH REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT
TO ASSESS ACCOUNTING CONTROLS
OF LOCAL AGENCIES TO VARIOUS
MONITORING ACTIVITIES AND SOME
PRESCRIBED BY CALTRANS LOCAL
ASSISTANCE. THE INDEPENDENT
OFFICE OF AUDITS AND
INVESTIGATIONS MONITORED THESE
ACTIVITIES THROUGH. PROCUREMENT
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION FINANCIAL
SYSTEMS AND PRE AWARD CONTRACTS.
TURNING SPECIFICALLY TO SB ONE
AND IT'S PROGRESS DID YOU KNOW
SB ONE REQUIRES CAL TRANS TO
IMPLEMENT AND REPORT ON SEVERAL
KEY ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES AND
SETS BY SPECIFIC PERFORMANCE
GOALS SB ONE ALSO REQUIRES
CALTRANS TO GENERATE AT LEAST
ONE HUNDRED MILLION PER YEAR
AND EFFICIENCIES TO REINVEST IN
MAINTENANCE AND REHABILITATION
OF THE STATE'S HIGHWAY SYSTEM.
THE INDEPENDENT OFFICE OF.
EDUCATION'S HAS CONDUCTED
SEVERAL AUDITS TO ENSURE THESE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS ARE MET.
BEGINNING WITH THE BASELINE FOR
SENATE BILL ONE PERFORMANCE
OUTCOMES THIS AUDIT WAS ISSUED
IN APRIL OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN. SB
ONE REQUIRES CALTRANS MEET
SPECIFIED PERFORMANCE
OBJECTIVES OVER THE NEXT TEN
YEARS INCLUDING THE EXPECTED
CONDITION OF ASSETS SUCH AS
PAVEMENT CULVERTS
TRANSPORTATION MANAGEMENT
SYSTEMS AND THE NUMBER OF
BRIDGES FIXED. THIS AUDIT WAS
DONE TO DETERMINE IF THE
ESTABLISHED BASS LINES AND
INVENTORY WAS SUPPORTED AND
RELIABLE AND IF CALTRANS HAD A
PLAN IN PERFORMANCE CRITERIA
FOR EACH OF THE ASSETS. THE
AUDIT DETERMINED THAT CALTRANS
IS MAKING PROGRESS TOWARDS THE
DEVELOPMENT OF PROCEDURES TO
ACHIEVE SB ONE PERFORMANCE
OUTCOMES. MOVING TO
EFFICIENCIES MY OFFICE
PERFORMED AN AUDIT OF
EFFICIENCY MEASURES THIS AUDIT
WAS ISSUED JULY TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
SB ONE REQUIRES CALTRANS TO
IMPLEMENT EFFICIENCY MEASURES
WITH THE GOAL OF GENERATING AT
LEAST ONE HUNDRED MILLION
ANNUALLY IN SAVINGS TO INVEST
IN MAINTENANCE AND
REHABILITATION OF THE STATE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM. THIS AUDIT
DETERMINED THAT. CALTRANS IS
MEETING THESE GOALS AND IN FACT
MET THESE GOALS THROUGH NEPA
VALUE ANALYSIS AND CONSTRUCTION
MANAGER GENERAL CONTRACTOR.
THEREFORE THE AUDIT DETERMINED
THEY CALTRANS PROGRAMS WERE PRO
ACTIVE IN IDENTIFYING AREAS OF
EFFICIENCIES AND DEVELOPING
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES TO
ACHIEVE THE ONE HUNDRED MILLION
IN KEEPING. WE'VE BEEN
PERFORMED AN EFFICIENCY
MEASURES VERIFICATION ON IT IN
ORDER TO DETERMINE WHETHER OR
NOT THE EFFICIENCIES THAT HAD
BEEN IDENTIFIED IN THE FIRST
AUDIT WERE ACTUALLY EFFECTIVE
AND WE'RE DOING WITH THE WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO ALSO TO BACK.
THE SAVINGS THAT CALTRANS
IDENTIFY ITS FIRST EFFICIENCY
REPORT. AND IN THE AUDIT WE
DETERMINED AGAIN BUT BE
CALTRANS WAS MEETING THE ONE
HUNDRED MILLION AND EFFICIENCY
SAVINGS- BASED ON THE AREAS OF
NEED BUT VALUE ANALYSIS AND SEE
HIM TO SEE THE AUDITORS ALSO
DETERMINED BUT EIGHT POINT
SEVEN MILLION OF THOSE AND
EFFICIENCY SAVINGS WERE OVER
REPORTED NONE THE LESS THEY DID
MEET THEIR EFFICIENCY
REQUIREMENTS. MOVING TO
PERFORMANCE OUTCOMES FOR
PAVEMENT. THE PURPOSE OF THIS
AUDIT WAS TO DETERMINE IF THE
DEPARTMENT HAS ADEQUATELY
ESTABLISH A BASELINE FOR
PAVEMENT CONDITION AND
BENCHMARKS FOR ACHIEVING PAPER
PERFORMANCE TARGETS. THE
AUDITOR'S DETERMINED THAT THE
DEPARTMENT ESTABLISHED A
BASELINE TO MEASURE PROGRESS IN
ACHIEVING THE PERFORMANCE
OUTCOMES FOR PAVEMENT
CONDITIONS. ESTABLISHED ANNUAL
BENCHMARKS FOR THE THREE ASSET
CLASSES THE PAVEMENT TO MEASURE
PROGRESS TOWARD ACHIEVING THE
SB WHEN PERFORMANCE TARGETS BY
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN. AND
IMPLEMENT A PROCESS OF SYSTEMS
TO TRACK ASSESS MONITOR AND
REPORT ON PAVEMENT CONDITION
AND PROGRESS TOWARD ACHIEVING
THE PERFORMANCE TARGET.
CALTRANS ALSO DEVELOPED
CORRECTION CORRECTIVE ACTION
PLANS TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE MADE IN
THIS ANALYSIS AND EVALUATION.
MOVING. FORWARD WE WILL
CONTINUE TO EVALUATE OR AUDIT
OF FISSION SEES AS THEY ARE
IDENTIFIED BY CALTRANS AND IN
FACT WE ARE ALSO LOOKING AT THE
EFFICIENCIES REPORTED FOR THE
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN REPORT TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE ARE RELIABLE
AND SUPPORTABLE. WE ARE ALSO
GOING TO BE GOING BACK AND
LOOKING AT THE PROGRESS TOWARDS
ACHIEVING THE SB WHEN
PERFORMANCE OUTCOMES PAVEMENT
WAS THE FIRST- OF THOSE- OF
THAT OF THOSE AUDITS THAT ARE
PLANNED WE INTEND TO GO BACK
CáC ON THE OTHER FOR ASSETS.
OF THAT ARE REQUIRED BY SB ONE.
WE ARE ALSO LOOKING AT PROGRAM
OVERSIGHT AND CAL RIPKEN
ABILITY FOR VARIOUS PROGRAMS
IDENTIFIED IN SB ONE. PURSUANT
TO CDC GUIDELINES CALTRANS
PROVIDES THE ADMINISTRATIVE
OVERSIGHT FOR SB ONE PROGRAMS
AND ENSURE IS THE TERMS AND
CONDITIONS OF THE CDC
GUIDELINES AND STEPS PROGRAM IS
ALLOCATION REPORTING AND OTHER
ACTIONS ARE FOLLOWED. THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY PLAN
INCLUDES OF ITS OF LOCAL
RECIPIENTS OF FUNDING UNDER THE
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM.
THE BILL OF THESE AUDITS IS TO
DETERMINE IF PROJECT COSTS
CLAIMED AND REIMBURSED ARE
SUPPORTED AND IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THE GREEN MATH AND
PROVISIONS IN STATE AND
FEDERAL. LAWS AND REGULATIONS.
WE ALSO BE LOOKING AT THE
EFFECTIVENESS AND ACCURACY OF
CALTRANS PROJECT COST
ESTIMATES. THE PERSON PURPOSE
OF THE STUDY IS TO DETERMINE IF
THE PROCESS FOR ESTIMATING
PROJECT COSTS CAN BE IMPROVED
TO REDUCE CALTRANS IS RISK OF
HAVING INSUFFICIENT FUNDS TO
COMPLETE PROJECTS WITH OVER
RUNS. OUT IT WILL BE A HISTORY
OF PROJECTS HEARING THE INITIAL
PROJECT ESTIMATE. FINAL PROJECT
AS AT THE TIME OF THE BID. AND
DO AND HOW CLOSE THE ORIGINAL
ENGINEERS ESTIMATE WAS. WE WILL
ALSO DO AN AUDIT OF DISTRICT
DIRECTORS BORDERS. WHICH IS A
FORMAL DOCUMENT APPROVING THE
WAIVER OF NORMAL PROCEDURES FOR
ADVERTISING BIDDING AND
AWARDING CERTAIN CONTRACTS WHEN
AN EMERGENCY OR OTHER
EXTENUATING CIRCUMSTANCES EXIST
THE DISTRICT DIRECTORS BORDERS
PROCESS WAS IDENTIFIED AS A
HIGH RISK THAT SHOULD BE
REVIEWED TO ENSURE CONTROL ARE
ESTABLISH TO GUARD STATE PARKS.
AND THEN LASTLY CALTRANS
EFFORTS AND SIMPLY SAFETY
CALTRANS NUMBER ONE GOAL IS TO
PROVIDE SAFETY TO ITS EMPLOYEES
AND THE PUBLIC WHO USE THE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM THIS
AUDIT PLAN INCLUDE OUT OF THE
TRANCE EFFORTS TO INCREASE THE
SOMEPLACE. CLOSE TO TAKE A SHE
MIGHT HAVE THE COMET SO I A ALL
OFF WITH THE GENERAL QUESTION-
IF YOU PROJECT THE REVENUES
AHEAD. THAT YOU'RE LOOKING TO.
WILL WE BE ABLE TO COMPLETE ALL
THE PROJECTS THAT WE COLLUDED
IN SP ONE. IN TERMS OF THE
PERFORMANCE REQUIREMENTS IN SB
ONE. IS IT LOOK LIKE WE'RE ON
SCHEDULE DO WE HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY ARE WE COMPLETE THE
PROJECTS OF. IN A TIMELY MANNER
IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE LAW.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN FOR A FOR A
QUESTION WE BELIEVE SO I MEAN
IT'S A TEN YEAR BILL AND
ROUGHLY. FIFTY FOUR FIFTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS- WE PRAY
BELIEVE WE CAN WE CAN WE CAN
GET THERE YOU KNOW. PART OF THE
CHALLENGE OBVIOUSLY IN THE IN
THE IN. IS THE FACT THAT THE
WAY WE PAY FOR TRANSPORTATION
IS BECOMING THE MODEL IS
BECOMING DATED- AS WE SPEAK.
THE MORE WE SHIFT TO- ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES- THE MORE.
THE ACCOUNT THAT WE USED TO
BUILD THE TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM- STARTS TO TAKE A TRIP-
SO. LOOK IT LOOKS LIKE WE'RE
COMPLETING ALL THE WORK THE
ABSOLUTE IS YES THE ONE WAS A
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG BASICALLY
THE TRUCK LIKE. WE HAD THIS MAY
CPAC LUGGAGE SIR BUILT UP. BOTH
THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL AND
YOU KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO A-
REDUCE ALL OF. AIR QUALITY.
FACILITIES TO IS OUR GOOD OF
YOU HAVE THAT STANDARD. SO
WE'RE LOOK IT LOOKS LIKE HOW
MANY YEARS BEFORE WE GET TO THE-
STANDARD WELL THE PLAN IS TEN
YEARS THE PLANTS TEN YEARS AND
FIFTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS SO
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE FOCUSED ON
WERE FOCUS ON EXACTLY WHAT THE
LOSSES WE DO BUT WE- SOME OF
MY- COLLEAGUES THAT.WE ARE NO
AND I'M SURE YOU BUT THIS
EFFORT WITH THE ROAD USER
CHARGE. THAT'S THAT'S BEING
WORKED ON. HOW WE CAN THAT
SHIFT THAT. ON THE LINE. NOT
JUST PAIN. OUT COMING FROM-
FROM FROM FROM GAS TAX AND
DIESEL TAX BUT- OF THE PLAN TO
DO THAT WERE FULLY FOCUS ON
RIGHT NOW IS ABSOLUTELY GETTING
THAT FIFTY FOUR BILLION DOLLAR.
AT LEAST A PART OF IT THE
LITTLE GIRL. SO YOU'RE ARE WITH
THE OTHER HALF OF THE FIFTY.
FIFTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS BUT
ARE PART OF IT WE'RE COMPLETELY
LOCKED INTO SEEN THAT WE MEET
THAT FIX IT FIRST. REQUIREMENTS
COMMENTS FROM OTHERS. DOES THE
COMMISSION REVIEW THAT AND HAVE
THE THEY HAVE. IS A RECALL LIKE
QUARTERLY REPORTS. ARE THEY
SHOWING- ANY RED FLAGS ON THIS
THIS ISSUE OF KEEPING ON A TIME
SCHEDULE TO COMPLETE ALL THE
PROJECTS. SO BAD THAT THE
COMMISSION IS REQUIRED TO BASED
ON THE INFORMATION CALTRANS TO
PRESENTS TO REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE PROGRESS
TOWARDS MEETING THE SP ONE
GOALS. WE WE'VE REPORTER ONCE
AND INDICATED CALTRANS IS
PROGRESSING TO MEET TACKLES AT
THAT TIME WHICH IS A LITTLE
OVER A YEAR AGO THERE WAS A
COUPLE OF AREAS WHERE WE STILL
NEEDED TO TECH. COME TO TERMS
OR WHAT THE DEFINITION OF THE
GOAL WHAT SAMPLE WHAT DOES FIX
FIVE HUNDRED ME AND CAME WHEN
AGREEMENT ON THE COMMISSION
ADOPTED WHAT IS FIX ME WE HAVE
A CERTAIN LEVEL. WE'RE DOING
RIGHT NOW CRAP PENSION HER TO
HER OFFICE LOOKED INTO THAT.
THE PAVEMENT SAID THAT IT
DIDN'T. SEEM THERE WITHOUT THEM
A C. OF. FOLLOW UP THAT AUDIT
AND WHAT THEIRRESPONSE WILL BE
TO AND REPORTING. BUT CAN YOU
ON WHAT WE'VE BEEN EVERY WITH
TO SEE WHO'S- WORDS. THE SO
CAN. HAVE OUR STAFF AND OUR
SALES IN. THE ISSUE NOW BOB SO
I WANTED AS TO SECRETARY. SINCE
VERY FROM ERROR WASH DC IN THE
TRANSPORTATION FIND OUT WE IN
OUR IN OUR OVERALL BUDGET WE
GET TO- FEDERAL GASOLINE TAX-
HIGHWAY TRUST FUND- MONIES WE
GOOD MONIES FOR TRANSIT
PROJECTS AND SO FORTH. AND
GERMAN TO FIVE ZERO A FEW WEEKS
AGO- PRESENTED THE HOUSE. OF
FRAMEWORK WHICH I PASSED OUT TO
ALL THE ALL THE MEMBERS THEY
ALL HAVE A COPY OF IT- THE FOR
HOUSE FRAMEWORK. IDENTIFIES
THERE. THE APPROACH TO- FUNDING
HIGHWAY TRANSIT- WATER ALL IT
GOES BEYOND JUST TRANSPORTATION
HOW DOES WHAT THEY'RE PROPOSING
FIT IN TO OUR SB WHAT OUR GOALS
ARE DIRECTIONS- IS IT THE
CONSISTENT OR AND WHAT DO YOU
HAVE AN OPINION ABOUT THE
FRAMEWORK OF YOU DEVELOP
DECISION A POLICY POSITION ON
THE FRAMEWORK. OF THE
SUPPORTING IT ASKING FOR
CHANGES OR WHAT IS YOUR
POSITION RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN. THERE IS A LOT TO
LIKE IN THE HOUSE FRAMEWORK-
RECENTLY RELEASED BY CHAIRMAN
TO FALL ZERO. IN FACT. WHAT YOU
SEE IN THE FREE MARKET IS-
REFLECTIVE OF THE PRINCIPLES
THAT WE PUT OUT LAST FALL-
CALIFORNIA POLICY PARTY
PRINCIPLES FOR RE AUTHORIZATION
OF THE FAST ACT RIGHT AND SO
THERE IS A LOT OF SYNERGY. OF
NOTE THE- THE HOUSE FRAMEWORK
INCREASES OVERALL PROPOSES TO
INCREASE OVERALL FUNDING
ACROSS. ALL MODES THAT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT COMES TO INTERCITY
PASSENGER RAIL AND ROAD IN OUR
REAL A HUGE BUMP UP WHICH IS
IMPORTANT FOR CALIFORNIA- THERE
ARE ALSO PROVISIONS PERTAINING
TO CLIMATE CHANGE RESILIENCY.
SAFETY TRANSIT SO THERE IS A
LOT TO LIKE IN THE HOUSE FROM
WORK ON PERSONALLY EXCITED
ABOUT IT. I ALSO WANT TO
MENTION THAT THE ON THE ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE COUPLE THE U.
S. SENATE. ENVIRONMENT PUBLIC
WORKS COMMITTEE OF REPORTED A
BILL LAST FALL. WHICH ALSO IS
VERY ROBUST IN NATURE- AND-
INCLUDES A RESILIENCE GRANT
PROGRAMS SO. WHETHER YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE U. S. SENATE
BILL OR THE HOUSE FRAMEWORK.
THERE IS A LOT TO LIKE- I
SHOULD MENTION THAT- DIRECTOR-
SHOCKING AND I. WILL BE IN
WASHINGTON- LATER THIS MONTH
TO. MAKE THE ROUTER THE OFFER
CONGRESSIONAL TO THEM TO DO.
CAN THIRTIES AS IN THE WE WILL
OUT LAST TALK ABOUT THE HEALTH
FROM ACROSS WELL SO A VERY
ABOUT WITH THE HOUSE HAS PUT
OUT AND WITH THE U. S. SENATE
HAS ALREADY REPORTED. LIKE TO
SEE. ANY INFORMATION REGARDING-
THE STATE THE- POSITION ON THE
FRAMEWORK THE UPCOMING I THINK
I THINK. THE LEGISLATION WILL
PROBABLY BE TAKEN UP POST
ELECTION I WOULD IMAGINE SO
IT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW
IS THERE SERVE HAVING THE FIELD
HEARINGS GETTING READY- WOULD
THEY HAVE A IN CALIFORNIA ON
THE INFRASTRUCTURE. THE
FRAMEWORK FOR I THINK THERE'S A
REASONABLY GOOD CHANCE AND- IN
FACT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIA CONGRESSIONAL
MEMBERS ON THE TEAM AND I CAN
READ- CHAIRMAN DEFAULT WHO HAS
VISITED ON VISIT ORANGE COUNTY-
AND OTHER PLACES AROUND THE
STATE- WE ARE MEETING WITH HIS
STAFF AND WILL ENCOURAGE HIM
TO. TO DO A FEW MORE IN
CALIFORNIA SO AGAIN I THINK
THAT THE CONGRESSIONAL
DELEGATIONS WELL PLACED AND
WELL POSITIONED TO. ADVOCATE
FOR THE STATE'S NEEDS SINCE
THERE ARE QUITE A FEW OF THEM
ON THE COMMITTEE RIGHT I YEAH I
HOPE THAT WE CAN GET. SOME
FIELD HEARINGS BECAUSE- IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO HOME. IS GOING TO
BE A PARTNER THE OUGHT TO KEEP
PACE WITH THE FUNDING. THAT
WE'VE DONE WITH SP ONE SO IF
THEY FALL BEHIND THAT JUST
DIMINISHES OUR EFFORT WITH SB
ONE CORRECT RIGHT RIGHT AND AS
YOUKNOW THE PERENNIAL QUESTION
WASHINGTON IS HOW TO PAY FOR. A
LARGE RIGHT PROGRAM THERE IS NO
SUCH CONSENSUS YET WHETHER IT'S
INCREASING THE GAS TAX
INDUCTING INDEXING IT USING
SOME MORE OTHER FORMER FINANCE
SO THEY HAVEN'T GOTTEN THERE
YET BUT AT LEAST THEY HAVE A
FRAMEWORK A PROPOSED AND THE
QUESTION BEFORE THEM IS HOW DO
YOU PAY FOR IT. OKAY SIR SKIN
ANSWER BATES. CAN WE GO BACK TO
THE JUDGE. FIRST QUESTION
BECAUSE WHEN WE HAD OUR INITIAL
HEARINGS ON SP ONE WE
IDENTIFIED A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SEVEN. BILLION DOLLARS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS WE'VE COME
UP WITH FIFTY FOUR WE SORT OF
DRIFTED DOWN SAID LET'S PUT
DOCTOR IN THERE. SO WHAT ABOUT
THE REST OF IT YOU KNOW IN TEN
YEARS HOW ABOUT THE OTHER
EIGHTY THREE BILLION THAT WE
ONCE UPON A TIME. IDENTIFIED
IT'S NOT INCLUDED IN SB ONE
WHAT ABOUT THAT. QUESTION
QUESTION CENTER AND AS I THINK
EVERYBODY IN THE TRANSPORTATION
WORLD KNOWS JUST BE ONE WAS A
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT DOWN
PAYMENT IT DOESN'T COVER ALL
THE NEEDS AND SO WITH THE
AVAILABLE FUNDING WE HAVE- IT'S
REALLY POOR TO TAKE A RISK
BASED APPROACH- TO ADD ON A
DRESS THE MOST PRESSING NEEDS
WHETHER IT'S ON PURPOSE
CORPORATE. TOTALS AND WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO FIGHT OTHERS AND-
THAT'S THE TO TELL TO FROM US.
TURKEY WE SUFFER GOT TECH
GRADUATE YOU ALSO FOR YOUR
APPOINTMENT. HOW ABOUT FROM SEA
TO SEA OUR PERSPECTIVE. WELL I
THINK SECRETARY KIM WAS EXACTLY
RIGHT- WE IDENTIFY AS YOU
POINTED OUT WE IDENTIFIED A
NEED THAT WAS EVEN LARGER THAN
SB ONE WE CAN ONLY DO WHAT WE
HAVE FUNDING FOR. I'M NOT A
CHECK. CLIMATE RESILIENCY
ADAPTATION AND FIX THE FIRST
ONE COULD ARGUE THAT THEY MAY
HAVE BE. COMPETING FORCES
BECAUSE SOME OF THE ADAPTATION
EFFORTS THAT WE NEED TO TAKE WE
JUST DON'T NEED TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT THE TRANSPORTATION PEOPLE
WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT THE FLOOD
CONTROL PEOPLE WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT WITH THE CLIMATE PEOPLE
WHAT ARE THE OTHER FACTORS THAT
ARE HAPPENING THAT ME EXPAND HE
THE LIFE OF SOME OF OUR ROADS
IN IT IN A DISTRESSED AREA WERE
THAT. FOR A SHORTENED THEM IF
WE DON'T DO ANYTHING ON
ADAPTATION SO MY QUESTION IS
THAT. DO YOU CAN THINK OF PARTS
OF HIGHWAY ONE WHEN WE KNOW IF
WITH SEALEVEL RISE ARE GOING TO
BE UNDER WATER. SO WHAT IS YOUR
THINKING DO IF NOTHING HAPPENS
THE OTHER SOME EXTERNAL THESE
THAT ARE GOING I'M WERE CHANGES
ARE BEING MADE ON ALAMEDA
CREEK. MITIGATE UP TO ONE THIRD
OF SEA LEVEL RISE WHEN DO YOU
GUYS GET THAT INFORMATION THAT
WOULD HELP YOU WHAT YOU'RE
PLANNING ON WHETHER WE ASK.
SURFACE R- PROPOSAL OF A
DIFFERENT HOUSE HAD ALL GET
WORKED OUT OF ALL STARTED IN
ALL ALL HAVE DIRECTOR WITH
SHOCK AND TALK ABOUT WHAT
CALTRANS HAS BEEN DOING ITS OF
ASSESSMENTS. THE CHALLENGE IS
HOW TO PAY FOR UP PROJECTS THAT
INCREASE THE RESILIENCY OF A
TRANSPORTATION ASSET. I BELIEVE
IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN SB ONE DID
HAVE A PROGRAM FOR THAT PURPOSE
AND IT MAY HAVE IT MAY HAVE
BEEN LAST FOR A COUPLE YEARS-
THERE NEEDS TO BE ADDITIONAL-
WAYS TO COVER THAT- THAT'S
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. IS ALSO MENTIONED IN
THE OF THE HOUSE FRAMEWORK WE
JUST DISCUSSED AS WELL AS THE
U. S. SENATE BILL SO THAT'S
GONNA BE THE CHALLENGE GOING
FORWARD HOW DO WE COVER THE
COST TO MAKE THESE PROP
PERSONALLY. AND WITHOUT THE
DIRECTOR TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHAT CALTRANS BEEN DOING
TO US RESILIENCY AT THAT LEVEL.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU SIR
TURKEY OUT SENATE. EXCELL
QUESTION AND- NOT I THINK IT
REALLY DESERVES A GREAT
RESPONSE AS WELL THAT WILL
PROBABLY TAKE A LONG TIME FROM
FROM. OUR FROM OUR END BUT ALL
ALL TOUCH WITH TWO THINGS VERY
QUICKLY NUMBER ONE. ONE RIVAS
WAS EXCITED TO COME HERE AND
TAKE ON THIS THIS
RESPONSIBILITY. WAS THE AMOUNT
OF WORK THAT WAS ALREADY
HAPPENED WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
AROUND THE STRUCTURE. AND HAS.
WE HAVE TWELVE DESTROY. TEN OF
THOSE THE HOW FINALIZE WHAT WE
CALL OF THE BILL ASSESSMENT
REPORT. SO THOSE
VULNERABILITIES. BLOW THINGS
THAT YOU LIKE SEA LEVEL RISE-
AND WHERE WE HAVE PHONE
ABILITIES WITHIN OUR NETWORK-
AND WE'VE ALSO GOT TAKEN THE
NEXT STEP WE'RE WORKING ON.
DEPUTATION PLANS IT SO WHAT WE
NEED TO BEYOND. A DONE A FINE
PHONE A BILL ARE TO HAVE ST. WE
BUILD THE PROJECT WERE. I THANK
YOU KNOW WORK THROUGH OUR TOPIC
OF A PROCESS HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE. THAT WE ARE DRY THE THOSE
FORMER BILL THAT WERE GOING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THINGS LIKE SEA
LEVEL RISE YOU MENTIONED. THAT
WE CAN SOMEHOW ADDESS IT.
NUMBER TWO JUST QUICKLY.
PENSION THE FACT THAT THERE'S
POSH THERE'S A THERE'S SOME
CONTENTION THERE A CONFLICT
BETWEEN THEM BETWEEN THOSE TWO
BETWEEN THOSE TWO THINGS- I
THINK THERE ARE SOME- THERE
SOME LINKAGES AS WELL THAT WE
NEED TO DISCUSS A LITTLE BIT
MORE- AN EXAMPLE OF THAT IS AS
WE DO A FIX IT FIRST. IT WAS A
WERE RESURFACING ROAD. WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING FOR MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MOBILITY
OPTIONS SO FOR EXAMPLE WERE
SERVICE IN A ROW WE CAN FIT IN
A PLANO CAN FIT IN. OF A BUT
THIRTEEN TRADE SERVICE. THINGS
LIKE THAT THEY ACTUALLY
ULTIMATELY HELP MOBILITY WHICH
REDUCES EMISSIONS WHICH- HELPS
WITH THE CLIMATE CHALLENGES WE
FACE. SO WITH THEIR SEVENTY ONE
THERE ARE WE NEED TO MAKE THE
ACTION. NOTES OF IT FIRST.
ABSOLUTELY. FORTUNE WHAT THAT'S
DON'T FORCES WILL BE A AYE
WHICH IS OFFERED AS A YOU KNOW
AS AN IDENTIFIED WE ALL KNOW
THAT THERE'S PROBLEMS WITH
HIGHWAY THIRTY. SEVEN I DON'T
WITH THE NAPA I'VE BEEN THE
NAPA IN IN WE ALL KNOW THE BIG
ANSWER WHICH WILL INCREASE
RESILIENCY AN ADAPTATION IS TO
BUILD A BRIDGE. AND ALL THAT
THAT WE HAVE THIS SURGE OF
WATER TO GO UNDERNEATH IT AND
IT WILL BENEFIT THE ENTIRE BAY
AREA. NOT JUST THE NAPA PEOPLE
NOW WHETHER THAT'S A P. THREE
OR CENTER. ON A NEW BILL WHAT
THE HELL FOR FUN FIRM WHERE
HOWEVER THAT GETS DONE. IN WE
ALL KNOW THAT THAT'S THE TO DO
WE PRAY. AND ALL. THE LOBBYING.
PEOPLE MISTER. MY THE- INTERNET
WAS TRYING TO MAKE IS THAT DO
WE- SPEND MONEY. REPAVE AT ARE
PUTTING A BIKE LAKE IN A THE
EGGS. RAY RIGHT NOW ON KNOW
THIS IS AN IDEA. AS ONE OF.
WAS JUST. THAT'S WHAT I'M-
WONDER BECAUSE THERE THINGS
GOING ON LIKE IN THE FLOOD CAN.
IN THESE OTHER AREAS ON RISK.
AND PROCESSES BE SEE D. C. ALL
THESE OTHER FOLKS THAT ARE.
OUTSIDE THE CHURCH. IN A BUT-
PACKED ISSUE SAID WOULD CAPS.
CHANGES A LEVEL RISE TO OFFICER
YOU GUYS TO ACCOUNT. AND SAYING
ARE WE SHOULD REPAY THAT
BECAUSE NOT GOING TO BE ON THE
WATER OR MAYBE. WHATEVER THAT
IS CENTER. THERE'S
COLLABORATION THESE AREAS
BEYOND JUST THE WORLD OF TRANCE.
THAT NEEDS. AND THOSE PLANNING
PROCESS SECOND THE TO IT TO
TAKE ALSO. THEY ARE THEY'VE IT
I LIKE TO. YEAH SMART MORE
MONEY SO PRETEND I HAVE A- WELL
YOU'LL SPEND ANY WE'VE THIS.
FEDERAL INFRASTRUCTURE
FRAMEWORK AND IF I JUST USE A-
12% CALIFORNIA'S POPULAR THAT
THE HUNDRED AND FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS THAT THEY WANT TO PUT
IN TRANSIT THAT WOULD BE
THIRTEEN BILLION BOX IN IN THE
RAPE INVESTMENTS FIFTY FIVE
THAT'S THE SIX MAY HAVE TOLD
HIM NOT. TO ART. ARE TWENTY
BILL. THAT THAT THAT WOULD COME
IN WE GOT THE- MORE CUTS
MEMBERS HERE WE CAN PROBABLY
FIRE OVER THAT FROM EUROPE FROM
THE CTC AND WE GET A LOT OF
CONVERSATION ON HIGH SPEED RAIL
WHETHER WE SHOULD FINISH THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL BLUE SOME OF
THE MONEY TO THE BOOKENDS WE'VE.
IN A CITY. THE TRAIN THE COME
THROUGH FREE ONE WHERE I LIVE
DE CONNECT WITH THE BALL IN
THAT SEEMS LIKE A OBVIOUS FOR
THE CAPITAL CORDER THERE EIGHT
IN THE BART AND THE DUMB
PARTNERING YOU THINK HEY HOW
ABOUT HEY PLANNERS ONE WE HAVE
ONE STATION. DOES THAT CONFLICT.
THIS THING MERCH IF I HAD CHUNK
OF TWENTY BILL BOX FROM THE
FEDERAL. TO SPREAD OUT LIKE
PEANUT BUTTER OR DO WE- DO A
COUPLE OF. TRANSFORM PRIDE TO
ARE GOOD HAVE A IMPACT YOUR-
SINCE YOU GUYS ARE WITH. EIGHT
SIR THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION AND
SPREE. YEAH SO I. THE ANSWER
WILL BE. THE ON HOW THE LAW IS.
WHAT THE WHAT'S THE-
REQUIREMENT HOW CAN YOU USE
THOSE FOR. DOES IT HAVE TO BE
EXISTING RAIL OR AS YOU SAY
TRANSFORMATIVE NEW EXTENSIONS
SO REAL REFUSE TO SEEN HOPKINS
IT IS IT FOR. IS IT A GRANT
PROGRAM BUT CLEARLY YOU POINTED
TO THE TO THE CHILD WHICH IS.
IF FORGET GIVEN A CHUNK OF
MONEY SAY TWENTY BILLION. HOW
TO USE IT FOR- THAT IT SHE-
GOALS. THANK YOU. THAT IS TRUE
TO THE SUCH GOING TO BE THE
CHALLENGE FOR US. CITIES IN THE-
HI THERE BRIAN ALWAYS SAID I
THE SEC ARTICULATE IT VERY
CLEAR THE FEDS ARE NOT JUST
GONNA GIVE US MONEY WAY WITHOUT
TELLING US HOW TO SPEND IT. THE
STATE LET MAY WISH TO WEAR ON
ON HOW TO IT YOU KNOW IT'S UP
AUSTIN TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
IMPLEMENT THAT. BUT THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THAT'S A OF MONEY BUT
AT NOT ENOUGH MONEY. THE ONE
THING YOU WANT THINGS I WOULD
SAY ON YOUR QUESTION IS THAT-
PAST PRACTICE HAS BEEN TO FIND
THINGS SO. THE PAY AS THEY GO
ALONG. AND WHAT THAT ENTAILS IS.
ALL THESE DIFFERENT PHASES
RIGHT LIKE ARE PART PROJECT
RIGHT TO SAN JOSE ALL THESE
DIFFERENT PHASES AND YOU HAVE
TO DO THREE FOR A OURS THREE OR
FOUR AND DURING PLANS ROUTE
YEAH SO. THE WHOLE IDEA OF
MULTI YEAR FUNDING SHOLD BE
APPROACHED WE DID SB NINE A FEW
YEARS AGO IT ALLOWED. THE
TRANSIT FUNDS TO BE MULTI YEAR
GRANTS. AND I THINK THAT'S A
GOOD DIRECTION THAT NEEDS TO BE
EXPLORED MORE. IT WHETHER OR
NOT THAT'S A GOOD DIRECTION
GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE'RE
HAVING THIS FASTER. YOU KNOW
THIS SO. FEDERAL FRAMEWORK-
PROPOSAL WE NEED TO LOOK AT
LIKE SERVE HOW WE PLAN AND BILL
PROJECTS MULTI YEAR FUNDING.
AND DEVELOP A MULTI YEAR PLAN.
LIKE FEDERAL NEWS STARTS
PROGRAM USED TO DO I MEAN THEY
STILL DO IT RIGHT YES IF SO-
WHEN WE WHEN WE DEVELOP THAT.
SB NINE. THE WAS SOMETHING THAT
WE MODELED AFTER THE NEW
STARTS. KANEMOTO YOUR BUT THIS
A CONTRACT IF YOU HAVE TO SPEND
THE MONEY AT CERTAIN DATE. THIS
ONLY WE CAN BUILD THE THOSE
KINDS OF PROJECTS I THINK SO I
THINK ITHINK THAT WOULD BE A
GOOD MODEL FOR WHAT SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE HE'S TALKING ABOUT
THESE BIGGER SCALE. PROJECTS
THAT MIGHT INVOLVE MANY
DIFFERENT SOURCES OF MY- MY IN
A FOUR FIVE. SINCE WE HAVE THE
CT SEEING CALTRANS HERE MISTER
CHAIR THAT WOULD BE THE PART
SANTA CLARA. SHOULD WE GET TO
THE END OF THE- OF THE CYCLE IN
IN MY DISTRICT COULD IN AT THE
LEVI'S. OKAY LEAVE. OKAY SIR.
HAS SOME CORE. SINCE SPEED WELL
AS MEN I DO WANT TO OUT THAT
DON'T ALL KNOW THE OF A TRANSIT
PROJECT AND WHILE THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF COPPER. ABOUT US OF
SPEED RAIL WHEN CONGRESS I HAD
MY UP TODAY WITH THE FACT THAT
FOR A ONE POINT SIX MILE
STRETCH AND THIS IS A- POINT
SIX MILES BRIDGE. OF THE PERSON
AND SAN. THE COP ONE FOR IN.
STRUGGLE TO TRY TO. ONE OF OVER
THE LAST DOLLARS FOURTH MY- OF
HIGH RAIL IN THIS ALI TO
CONNECT. NUMBER SEVEN WORKING
CONNECT WITH THE OUT. PRESS
THAT ALREADY GOES INTO SANTA
CLARA CARRYING THOU OF AREA
WORKER WHERE THE JOB CENTERS
ARE. I WILL POINT OUT THAT IN
THE- AND THE LATE. IT WAS A
PRIOR. TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW
WE COULD GET MORE HOUSING AND
JOBS RICH AREAS AND MORE JOBS
IN HOUSING RICH AREAS LIKE THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THE ECONOMY WAS
DOWN TO THAT. AND WINNER WITH
THE FINDING IT TO THAT KIND OF
THING AT RESULT STAGE CONTENT
TO MOVE INTO CENTRAL. AND SIR
AFFORDABLE. KNOWING THAT THE
TRUCK OFF THREE TO SIX HOURS A
DAY. COMMUTER HIGHWAY TO THE
JOHN BIRCH. SO AS WE LOOK AT
TRANSIT PRO AND TRY FINE I JUST
WANT MAKE SURE WE WERE. THOSE
KIND. WHO ACTED RESPONSIBLY I
KNEW THEY NOT AFFORD HOMES AND
THE BAY AREA AND THEY MADE LIFE
CHANGING CHOICES. SPEND THREE
AND SIX HOURS A DAY ON THE ROAD
SO THAT THEY COULD HAVE. FAN IS
SO IN YOU WERE THE FINDING A
WERE CAR. ABOUT WHETHER PRIDE
IS BY ARE NOT I WON AT EVERYONE
TO RE THAT SPEED RAIL IS VIABLE
NOT ONLY FOR THE TRANSIT THAT
IT PROVIDES BUT THE ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR THOSE
WHO CANNOT AFFORD TO LIVE IN
THE AREA. OKAY THANK. I JUST
HAVE ONE LESS QUESTION FOR THE
SEARCH OF MAYBE IT IS A
DIFFERENT AGENTS BUT WHEN THE
FOR GOVERNMENT CHANGED VEHICLES
THE HOT AIR QUALITY STANDARDS.
HOW DOES THAT AFFECT THE
COMPLETION PROJECTS A CALTRANS
ANY OTHER PROJECTS AND- OF WHAT
IS WHAT IS THE RESPONSE FOR
THAT IF YOU'RE REFERRING TO THE
SAFE VEHICLES RULE ONE YES I AM
YES SO. MY WAY BACKGROUND YOU
PROBABLY KNOW THIS THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION ISSUED THEIR
THEIR FIRST RULE PART ONE A FEW
MONTHS AGO TOOK EFFECT IN
NOVEMBER. AND UP PART COMING
OUT SOMETIME IN THE NEAR
FUTURE- COMBINED THOSE RULES-
COULD HAVE A POTENTIALLY-
DEVASTATING IMPACT ON PROJECT
DELIVERY CALIFORNIA IT'S A
TACTICAL THE- BUT THE UPSHOT IS
THAT. THE EMISSIONS USED BY CAR.
HIS OWN MIND BY THE US HE- IT'S
A RULE NOW I SAY THAT CARBON
HAS COMPLETED ALL OF THE
MODELING A JOE THE HAVE SOME TO
A EVERYTHING OF THE- AND THE
BALL IS IN. COURT EPA WORK WITH
THE FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION.
ISSUE CONFORMITY
DETERMINATIONS- AND SO THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE WAITING FOR RIGHT
NOW I WILL SAY THAT. ACTION A
FEW MONTHS AGO TO MAKE SURE
THAT FREE M. P. O.'S. SLOW AUG.
SIXTH AUG IN SENDAI HOW THE
REGIONAL TO. PLANS OF. BEFORE
THE EFFECTIVE. OF SAFE VEHICLES
WERE POP. ONE AT. THE WOULD
HAVE BEEN IN WORLD OF HER AND
WE ARE WORKING OTHER MP MPO
STRUCK STATE IN SAID ASK. EMPTY
AND WHOSE DOES ARE COME UP TO
HAVE THEIR OR PEAS APPROVE AND
SO WE ARE ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN
THIS WE HAVE A- INTERNAL
WORKING GROUP WORKING WITH ALL
OF THE PARTNERS. I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT IF. LIEU FIRM
BODY COULD. IT'S YES AS THAT
GOES ALONG WITH THE TO FOR THAT
THAT. OR PRO TO LOOK. PROBABLY
EFFECTOR BUT MAY THROUGH THE
BUDGET. IS IT SURE. ONLY
CERTAIN IT DELAYS THE WHICH
MAKE SOME MORE BASICALLY RIGHT
IS A IT IS DELAYS PROJECTS WHEN
HE DELIVER PRO A CALL MORE.
ESSENTIALLY IN A REQUIRE CHANGE
IN SOME THE BROAD RIGHT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS TO ISSUE
CAN JUST TO DETERMINE IF A PRO
NEEDS CLEANER RECALL. IF THAT
FOR ME TO TURN XIN ISN'T MAY.
THE PROJECT CANNOT GO FOR. AND
SO THE CONTENT BE FOR. TO
ANOTHER APPROVED PRIOR WORSE.
THIS COULD DEPEND ON THE COLOR
OF MONEY BUT AS SUCH IT WOULD
BE VERY TO. GOTCHA OKAY YOU.
SIR BATES YOU HAD A YOU'RE BACK
ALL THAT IN TIME BEFORE I GO
AHEAD SENATOR YEAH FOR THE ARE
OF SPECIFIC I YOU BROTHER THE
FACT THAT THERE IS THE FRAUD
REPORT. AND IT'S A AND RUNNING
WHAT IS THE USE ARE YOU GET YOU
KNOW REAP FROM YOU KNOW HERE IN
THE CAPITAL OR ON THE DISTRICTS
AND OF ALL ANY REPORTS ON. THE
FRAUD AND ABUSE OF A THE IS A
YOU SAID SHE OF THE ON THAT.
YES WE RECEIVE A PHONE CALL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE INCLUDING
CAL HICK DO OFF BUT THE PART
PRIMARILY. THE COMPLAINTS ARE
GENERALLY MY SUPERVISOR DOESN'T
LIKE ME THEY PASSED OVER ME FOR
FIVE TIMES FOR PROMOTIONS I
THINK I'M BEING RETALIATED
AGAINST. AND UP. MISS OF STATE
THE REAP TIME INCORRECTLY THOSE
TYPES OF THINGS WERE SAYING
NOTHING A MAJOR THAT RISES TO
THE LEVEL OF FRAUD WASTE ABUSE
AT LEAST TO THIS POINT. WELL
MAYBE THAT'S GOOD NEWS SALUTE
ABOUT SIDE IT IS THE TOXIC WORK
ENVIRONMENT ISSUES LIKE HAVE
MORE HR THAN IT IS WHAT YOU
INTENDED IT TO BE SO GOOD.
QUESTION TWO IF IT CAME UP BY
BEING CONCERN ABOUT WHAT I SEE
IS A MOUNTING CONGESTION AND IN
LAW THE LOCAL. WE WENT LOCAL SO.
HAVE THEIR OPPORTUNITY. CAN
REST TO THAT TO BED WITH THE
LOCAL PARTNERS IN THE RED. FOR
OB YEAH TRANSFERRED. ODD TO. AS
OF THIS DIET ON WHICH IS THE
TERMS THAT ARE BEING YOU OUT
THERE WE SEE A LOT OF MOUNTING.
ON SOME OF THE PRIMARY
ARTERIALS NOT THE MAJOR AS MUCH
AS THE LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS
AND- HERE ARE. OTHER CAN
COMMUNITIES. IN IS THERE GO TO
BE IN FOR US OF WHETHER THAT.
IS VALUE AS WE THINK TERMS OF.
THE I THINK THAT HADN'T TO DO
WITH MOVING PEOPLE OUT OF
AUTOMOBILES ON ON TWO BIKES
THINGS WERE CREATE LESS
GREENHOUSE ASSN IN MISSIONS BUT-
WHEN YOU'VE GOT THE OTHER. THE
OTHER LANE WITH WILL SIT CARSON
THANK YOU. FAME BOB I MEAN I
THINK THERE'S ACTUALLY A- OF
FORMULA. FOR IF YOU'RE SITTING
IN A CAR RAINING YEAH YOUR
MEETING YOU KNOW TOXIC FUMES
IT'S AS BAD AS YOU DON'T SO
MANY. ROADBLOCKS AND. THIRTY
MEASURE ABOUT GOING. KIND OF A
CAR TURNS AWAY REPORTING ON.
WELL I WOULD SAY WE AT THE
COMMISSION I'M NOT SOMETHING
LIKE THAT AS YOU POINT OUT THAT
MAY BE SO BASS BEST DANCE THE
LOCAL LEVEL WE SEEN THERE'D
BEEN A COUPLE OF. HI PUBLICIZED
CASES WHERE AT WHERE THAT'S
OCCURRED- I KNOW AT LEAST ONE
JURISDICTION WHERE THEY WHERE
THEY ON DID THAT- BUT I SURE
THERE ARE EQUAL NUMBER WHERE
THEY HAVEN'T DONE DONE IT. ON
DONE IT THEY'VE KEPT THE WEIGHT
IS A DOZEN HERE IN SACRAMENTO-
BUT- ONE THING I WOULD POINT
OUT IN OUR ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM WHICH IS
PARTLY FUNDED BY. BY SB ONE S.
ONE FOR. 80% INCREASE THAT
PROBE. ALTHOUGH PROJECTS ARE
LOCAL PRIORITY AND ALL. I PROUD.
BY THE- BY THE- BY THE RE
AGENCY. BURKE AN- EXTENSIVE
PUBLIC PARTISAN. COME TO HELP
THAT THAT THIS IS A PROJECT
THAT THAT'LL LOCAL AREA AND
THAT THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT WANTS
SO HOPEFULLY BY HAVING SUCH A
PROCESS WE WOULD- AVOID. SOME
THAT THE CHALLENGES THAT YOU'RE
FACING. ONE THING ALSO THROW IN
ONE OF THE THINGS WHERE WE'RE
LOOKING AT DOING IN THIS NEXT
CYCLE- IS- PILOTING A COUPLE OF
WHAT THEY CALL QUICK BUILD
PROGRAMS FOR THE ACTOR
TRANSPORTATION FROM DONE A
NUMBER OF THESE IN THE SAN JOSE
AREA. BUT THEY'VE DONE A COUPLE
OF. THROUGHOUT AND ALLOW IS A
CITY OR COUNTY TO GO TO GO AND
DO SOMETHING IT'S NOT GOING TO
BE PERMANENT IT CAN BE
CHANGEABLE. MAYBE IT MIGHT LAST
YOUR A COUPLE YEARS AND GET
MADE PERMANENT. IF IT'S
SUCCESSFUL BUT IT ALLOWS PEOPLE
TO LOOK AT WHAT THE RESULT THAT
MIGHT BE SO WITH THAT AREAS
WERE. INITIALLY BEEN. OUT FOR
EXAMPLE. BURKE AND BUSINESSES
SO BIZ DON'T WANT TO LOOSE
PARKING FOR A BI WEEKLY. BUT
WHEN THEY GET GET THE ACTOR
TRANSPORTATION. THEY FIND THAT
I HAS. IN CUSTOMERS SO THAT'S A
QUICK BUILD PILOT HAS ALLOWED
WOULD ALLOW SOMEOF THOSE TO
TRY IT. TO SEE IF IT WORKS
WE'RE NOT INVESTING AS MUCH
MONEY MAKING PERMITS. AND IF WE
FIND IT ISN'T SUCCESSFUL THEN
WE CAN GO JUST TO. ANSWER THE
QUESTION WHAT WOULD MAKE IT
SUCCESSFUL. I UNDERSTOOD
HOWEVER THAT. ARE TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR MATCHING FUNDS ON
SOME OF THESE TWO HAD TO HAVE
THAT AS A COMPONENT OF THE-
JEFF. I DON'T KNOW IF. THE ACT.
SHOP YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND OF.
THE FUND. I VISION IS FOR THE
LOCAL. BUT IF IT FROM THAT A
LOCAL HOUSE TO INCLUDE THE WHEN
THEY'RE AT IMPROVEMENTS ON THE
ARE. ARE THEIR PRIMARY THEIR
LOW ROSA THEY HAVE TO SOME
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION COMPONENT
OR THEY'RE NOT HIGH ON THE LIST
OF PRIVATIZATION FOR MATCHING
FUNDS YEAH I JUST SAY TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT BECAUSE IT SEEMS
TO BE ALMOST COMPETING.
INTERESTS THERE SURE AND OUR
LOCAL PARK PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM
IT FUNDS A WIDE VARIETY OF
PROJECTS- IT DOES NOT THE
REQUIREMENT THEY HAVE TO HAVE
AN ACTIVE. IN MAYBE THAT WOULD
SOMETHING THAT NOT THANK YOU
MISTER DIRECTOR. OUT SOONER
I'LL JUST QUICKLY AT LIKE A.
DIRECTOR WEISS ON THE ROLE
ISSUE I'VE- STAKEHOLDER IN IT
IS A- CRITICAL TO DO DOING
THOSE TYPE OF PROJECTS- WE
SHOULD MOVE FORWARD WITH A
PROJECT IF A COMMUNITY OR THE
SURROUNDING AREA SAY LOOK AT
THIS ONE OUT THIS WILL BE
SOMETHING WE WILL LIKE IN OUR
COMMUNITY. BUT I THINK YOU
TOUCHED SOMETHING VERY
IMPORTANT ABOUT. STAY AND DATA
TO UP DECISIONS AND WE SHOULD
DO MORE EVALUATING OF THAT.
I'LL TELL YOU THAT THE NATIONAL
STANDARDS AS IT RELATES TO THIS
ISSUE ARE IF A ROAD HAS TWENTY
THOUSAND VEHICLES LAST. TO BE
TO PROVIDE WORK THAT YOU DON'T
LOSE THE CAPACITY THEY'VE FROM
OF LANE A TO MY PART LINE
RATHER. THAT YOU DON'T MISTER
LOSE CAPACITY SO HIGH. VOLUME
ROAD WITH THIRTY VEHICLES AND
YOU DO THAT YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
SOME DETRIMENTAL IMPACTS- TO
THAT PARTICULAR FOR SCHOOL
FORTY NETWORK- BUT WE NEED TO
EVACUATE MORE USED. OPTIONAL
STANDARDS BUT I THINK. THREE
THIS IS. BUT RIGHT THE NOT ONLY
YOU THOSE MEASURE INSTEAD. THE
BUT ALSO ANTI APPOINT EVALUATE
BUT ALL MAKE SURE STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGE AS A AS A PART OF THAT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT IS YOU SEE
REMAIN A CON. AYE OUT THE AND
IF YOU FROM CA. AND IF IT'S NOT.
IT IS SOME THAT SHE BE YOU KNOW.
FROM OVERALL PLANNING OR A LONG
TERM PLANNING BETTER LEAD
AGAIN. GOES TO WHERE HE- THE
MORE. FOR MORE. BEYOND WE'RE
ALL POLITY OUTS. ONE FOCUSED ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. WE GOT A
COUPLE PAID SHOOTERS FROM OUR
PER PUBLISHED AGENDA. BECAUSE
OF ILLNESS FIGHT CANCELLATIONS
AND SO FOR THE. RONI VERTIGO IS
GOING TO SPEAK WITH THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES REPLACING RENEGE
WHERE FROM THE CITY POMONA. AND
KEEP DONE. WITH THE SELF CAL
COUNTIES COALITION. PLACES AND
SMITH WITH CINEMA
TRANSPORTATION ASSOCIATION AND-
WE STILL HAVE VETO I SEE YOU
DOES IT SHOWS IS- OR STANISLAUS
COUNTY SUPERVISOR AND- VIA HOW
MANY YEARS DID YOU SERVE AS A
C. SECTOR-LIMóN. JUST ONE YEAR
VETO WAS A CHAIRMAN OF C. SACK.
THERE WE STILL HAVE GORDAN
GARDEN MCKAY IF WITH THE-
PUBLIC WORKS DIRECTOR STOCKTON.
AND JIM LAWSON'S HERE FROM MY
COUNTY JIM LAWSON- HE'S- CHIEF
EXTERNAL AFFAIRS SANTA CLARA
COUNTY VALLEY TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY SO I BELIEVE VETO YOU'RE
GOING TO BE FIRST. SO IS THAT
WHAT YOU GUYS FIGURE THAT OUT.
OKAY THEATER. THE VETO IS FOR
STIR WELCOME GOOD TO SEE YOU
AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MIKE
VON IS A THERE WE GO. A GOOD
THE GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
MA'AM OF THE COMMITTEE. AS YOU
SAID I'M OKAY I'M KERR SIR. ON
THE STATE COUNTY BORDERS. I'M
ALSO THE PRESS OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S ASSOCIATION OF CAN.
AND TESTIFYING TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE SET PRESENTABLE FOR
EIGHT AND HE'S- AND I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE- TO ADD SOME
COMMENTS. I SEE SECOND COUNTIES
KISA OF ONE. BECAUSE OF A RE IS
THAT LOW ROAD. WERE TO BREAKING
POINT. OVER 80% OF THE PLANE
MILES A PUBLIC ROADS IN
CALIFORNIA- ARE OWNED BY CITIES
AND COUNTIES. THESE ROAD THE
ONLY SER CARS BUT THEY'RE ALSO
THE BACKBONE OF OUR PUBLIC
TRANSIT SYSTEM. AND THE RIGHT
AWAY FOR ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PUTTING WALKING AND BIKING.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT CITIES
IN QUE REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
POPULATIONS. TO GET TO THE A
COMPREHENSIVE ASSESSMENT OF THE
CAN. OF OUR LOW STREET AND
ROADS. INTO THE SEVENTEEN
COUNTIES WERE FACING THE
IMPOSSIBLE CHOICES LIKE
CANCELLING SIGNIFICANT- ROAD
REHABILITATION PROJECTS OR
ELIMINATING BASIC MAINTENANCE.
CLEANING CULVERTS AND SEE WHAT
THE CRACKS. WITHOUT NEW FUNDING
THE LOCAL MAINTENANCE BACKLOG
WOULD HAVE GROWN BY TWENTY
BILLION DOLLARS OVER A DECADE
REACHING NEARLY SIXTY BILLION
DOLLARS BY TWO TWENTY SIX.
PAVEMENT CONDITIONS WHEN IT
BEGAN TO RAPIDLY DETERIORATE
MORE THAN ONE OUT OF EVERY FIVE
MILES OF LOCAL ROADS WHATEVER
THEY FELT CAN INTENT THERE'S-
HE TO PER OF THE LOCAL. NETWORK
THAT THRESHOLD IS SIGNIFICANT
BECAUSE FAILED- PAVEMENT-
PAYMENTS MUST BE RECONSTRUCTED
RECONSTRUCTION COSTS ARE
EXPONENTIALLY HIGHER THAN
MAINTAINING ROADWAYS IN GOOD
CONDITION THAT'S WHY SB ONES
FIX. I'M HERE TODAY TO TEST SB
ONE HAS MEANT FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND AT THE START BY
COMMENTING COMMENTING ON WHAT A
DIFFERENCE TWO YEARS MAKES. THE
FIRST FROM SB ONE FLOW TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN FEBRUARY OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. DURING THE
FIRST TWO FISCAL YEARS OVER
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED LOCAL
PROJECTS HAVE BEEN PROPOSED BY
CITIES AND COUNTIES THIS
REPRESENTS NEARLY THREE POINT
FIVE BILLION IN PLANNED
INVESTMENTS. EIGHTEEN TO THE
PRIZE PLEADED STAY AS JUNE TWO
THOUSAND. HE SAID THE LEAGUE
AND A REPEAL A PARTNERS WILL BE
SERVED LOCAL. IN MONTH TO
UPDATE OUR WHY NEEDS IS
ASSESSMENT FOR THE YEAR. THIS
WILL BE THE FIRST NEEDS
ASSESSMENT THAT CAN DEMONSTRATE
THE IMPACT OF SB ONE FUNDING ON
LOCAL ROADS AROUND THE STATE.
MY COLLEAGUES FROM STOCKTON
EMILY WILL PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
DETAILS ABOUT OUR REMAINING
NEEDS IN THE UPDATE ON THIS
REPORT. IN THE MEANTIME- FROM
EXAMPLES AROUND THE STATE THAT
THESE FUNDS ARE FLOWING QUICKLY
TO THEIR INTENDED PURPOSE.
COUNTIES ARE MAKING SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS AND HAVE STARTED TO
SHIFT AWAY FROM THE TRIAGE AND
TOWARDS AN ASSET MANAGEMENT
APPROACH. IN MY OWN COUNTY
WE'VE USED SB FUNDS SB ONE
FUNDS TO RESURFACE FIVE HUNDRED
AND FOURTEEN MILES OF ROADS
PROVIDE MATCHING FUNDS TO
BRIDGES SEISMIC RETROFIT
PROJECTS. AND ALSO A LOCAL
BRIDGE FROM JECT OVER NEAR
GEISHA AND DISTRICT CANAL. SB
ONE BEEN TRANSFORMATIVE FOR MY
COUNTY AND THE SAME IS TRUE FOR
COUNTIES AROUND THE STATE. TO
THE SEVENTEEN YOU WITH ME.
WORLD COUNTY WAS COME A SENSE
ZERO MILE OF. OVERLAYS PER YEAR
WITH SB ONE THIS IS GROWING TO
FIFTEEN OR TWENTY MILES EACH
YEAR. IT DOESN'T SPEND TEAM
MONTEREY COUNTY WAS FACED WITH
DIFFERING SIGNIFICANT PAVEMENT
REHABILITATION OBJECTS OR
DRASTICALLY REDUCING. THE BASIC
MAINTENANCE. THE CAMPAIGN HAS
XCELERATED SIGNIFICANT PROJECTS
INCLUDING FULL DEPTH
RECLAMATION OF TWO MAJOR
ROADWAY SEGMENTS ONE FIVE MILES
LONG AND THREE POINT ONE MILES
LONG. IN THE COUNTY MAINTENANCE
WAS MINIMAL AND REACTIVE TO
SPECIFIC TROUBLE SPOTS HOUSE
THE TEAM. NOW SB ONE FOR THE
MUSICAL MANNING A PRO MAIN
APPROACH. SEND THE COUNTY IS
ALSO THIS FOR. THE COUNTY
INITIATED THE BUILDING BETTER
ROADS WORKING GROUP TO IDENTIFY
INNOVATIVE AND COST EFFECTIVE
APPROACHES FOR ROAD RESURFACING
EFFORTS. AS A RESULT OF THE
EFFORTS THE SB ONE FUNDING OF
AN SB ONE FUNDING THE COUNTY
HAS TURNED AROUND FORMER
DECLINING TREND IN THEIR PAY.
CAN INDEX. IN FACT LOCAL SB ONE
PROJECTS AROUND THE STATE
IMPROVING SAFETY AND BENEFITING
ALL MODES OF TRANSPORTATION.
MONTEREY COUNTY SB WANT TO
LEVERAGE FEDERAL BRIDGE IN
SAFETY FUNDS FOR SEISMIC
IMPROVEMENTS LIKE THE COUNTY
WIDE SAFETY STRIPING PROGRAM.
KERN COUNTY HAS MATCHED BACK TO
TRANSPORTATION GRANTS WITH SB
ONE DOLLARS THESE PROJECTS OF
FOCUSED ON IMPROVING BICYCLE
AND PEDESTRIAN ACCESS TO
SCHOOLS AND PARKS ESPECIALLY IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. I
JULY SAN DIEGO COUNTY WILL HAVE
REPAIRED OR BUILT FIVE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SEVEN ACCESSIBLE
CURB RAMPS FOR PEDESTRIAN AND
PAINTED OVER FIFTY MILES OF
BIKE LANES. IN ORANGE COUNTY
FUNDS ARE BEING USED TO IMPROVE
ACCESSIBILITY BY UPGRADING KERR
BRANDS AND CLOSE SIDEWALK GAPS.
THE IS ALL HELLO PRO ACTIVELY
PURSUE BY IMPROVEMENTS THAT CAN
BE ADDED TO FLOOD CONTROL
CHANNELS ROADWAY PROJECTS.
THESE PROJECTS WOULD DEPENDED
ON. FUNDS SB ONE ALSO CREATED
ON PUBLIC. EVERY COUNTY HAS
REPORTED TO THEIR PLAN PROJECTS
AN ACTUAL EXPENDITURES TO THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION IN ADDITION TO THE
STATE'S ONLINE PORTAL COUNTIES
ARE ENHANCING TRANSPARENCY AND
LOCAL PLANNING PROCESSES SAN
DIEGO COUNTY HAS BEEN A LEADER
IN THIS AREA THE COUNTY HAS AN
INTERACTIVE. AND YOU HAVE A
HAND OUT YOU CAN LOOK AT THAT
SHOWS THAT. FINALLY DESPITE ALL
THIS PROGRESS LOCAL GOVERNMENT
STILL HAS ON GOING NEEDS FIRST
WE NEED STABILITY AND
PREDICTABILITY FROM THE STATE.
COUNTIES HAVE APPRECIATE THE
LEADERSHIP OF CHAIRMAN BELL
CHAIRMAN FRAZIER AND OTHERS
HAVE WORKED HARD TO ENSURE THAT
SB ONE. ARE ALLOCATED TO THEIR
INTENDED PURPOSE WITHOUT DELAY.
SECOND CITIES AND COUNTIES
CONTINUE TO FACE SIGNIFICANT
BRIDGE MAINTENANCE AND
REPLACEMENT NEEDS. THESE
PROJECTS ARE UNIQUE AS EVEN A
SINGLE BRIDGE CAN TAKE UP TO
SEVERAL YEARS WORTH OF ROAD
MAINTENANCE FUNDING FOR A
SMALLER EIGHT. THIRD WE MUST
NEED TO STREAMLINE OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESSES TO
MORE QUICKLY DELIVER
MAINTENANCE READABLE BILLET
TATIAN AND SAFETY PROJECTS. C.
SECT TO THINK UNDER DOT FOR.
LAST YEAR THIS IMPORTANT WILL
HELP STREAMLINE LOCAL BRIDGE IN
SAFETY PROJECTS- BUT THERE'S
MUCH MORE THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
INCLUDING IMPLEMENTING SYKORA
NEPA RECIPROCITY ONCE FEDERAL
LEGISLATION IS FINALIZED. IF I
COULD LEAVE IT WAS ONE LAST
THOUGHT TELL YOU THE MAGNITUDE
OF HOW MUCH IS HELP THEM YET
HOW MUCH NEED IS OUT THERE
STANISLAUS COUNTY WE- AND IN
THE MONEY. GAS TAX FOR FIX IT
FOR. TO MAINTAIN FOR OTHER AND
FIFTY MY OF ROAD. TWO HUNDRED
AND PER BRIDGES CULVER SIGN
STOPLIGHTS EVERYTHING GOES WITH
FOR TWELVE MILLION WE WERE
FORCED AFTER A COUPLE ATTEMPTS
TO PASS A SELF HELP. TAX WHICH
BROUGHT IN ABOUT ANOTHER FOR.
MILLION ISN'T. JUST ABOUT 50%
TO OUR WHO. SB AS DOUBLE. THE
TOTAL AMOUNT UP ABOUT THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR US SO IT'S
COMPLETELY CHANGED THE
COMPLEXITY HAVING SAID THAT WE
ONLY EXPECT OUR REPAIR PAVEMENT
MANAGEMENT INDEX OR- EFFICIENCY
RATING. TO INCREASE BY TEN
POINTS OF NEXT TEN YEARS SO
IT'S STILL A LONG ROAD EVEN
WITH ALL OF FLUX IN MY- A-
WHERE IT WOULD. NO IS A IS A C.
BY OR AS A CITY I THINK OF HIM
MUCH OF THE SAME SO I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER THE QUESTIONS AT WELL
MICHAEL HAVE GONE THANK YOU GET
FOR THE TIME. THANK YOU VETO.
FOR WORK AS TERM OF. THOSE WE
SHOULD HAVE. A MCKAY IS SERVE
WORK DIRECTOR FOR. STOP AND GO.
OF I SAW EUROPE THE PRO WORKS.
COMMUNITY AS- I TRY TO YOU HAVE
THE FLOOR. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PLANES GORDON OKAY
PUBLIC OR DIRECTOR DIRECTOR THE
CITY OF STOCK FOR THE PAST
SEVEN YEARS. I'M ALSO THE OF
THE PUBLIC WORKS OFFICER DEPART
OF THE LEAGUE REPRESENT PUBLIC
WORKS PROCESS. AS THE COURTS
pPUBLIC WORKS DEPARTMENTS-
ACROSS THE STATE ARE LEGALLY
WHERE THE RUBBER MEETS THE ROAD
WE STRIVE TO DELIVER CRITICAL.
AND BILL SERVICES RESIDENTS
EVERYDAY. ON A BRIEF NEW
COUNCIL ON THE PUBLIC WORKS
DEPARTMENT DOES- USUALLY I TELL
THEM THAT. YOU'RE GONNA HEAR
PROBABLY THREE THINGS FROM THE
RESIDENTS. RESPECT TO PUBLIC
WORKS IN A BE QUESTIONS ABOUT
PAVEMENT. WE QUESTIONS ABOUT
SIDEWALKS SB QUESTIONS ABOUT
TREES AND THAT'S BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT'S IN FRONT OF THE HOUSE
DOESN'T WHERE THEY LIVE WHAT
THEY LOOK AT AND CARE ABOUT.
PEOPLE EXPECT INTEREST. THREE
MAINTAINED IN GOOD CONDITION.
THE CHALLENGE FOR LOCAL DOT.
AND STOCKED PARTICULARS FUNDING
TO PRESERVE THESE LOCAL ROADS
TRANSFERRED FUND IS- A
MULTILAYERED PUZZLE SALES TAX
TAX FEDERAL MONEY STATE MONEY
BUT USUALLY ALLOCATED TO SPICE.
THINGS UP MONEY TO THE FEDERAL
EASTER A LOT OF THE LOW SO HELP
CAN MONEY A DIRECT TOWARDS YOU
ARTERIALS CAN JUST ENGINE. IN A
CHUNKS TO TREAT BUT LITTLE
MONEY I DISCRETIONARY BECAUSE
OF IT FOR LOCAL ROAD ME. SO ALL
OF OTHER USE ARE YOU KNOW IN
VALLEY BUT IN IT BUT THE THAT
IS A IN THE WHAT BUT THIS SINCE
COMPLAIN OF AND WHAT THE OTHER
IS BUT THE ROAD LOOKS THE LOCAL
ROADS LOOK LIKE AND IS UNDER
RONNIE WILL. IT'S FUN TO SEE
ALL HOLD ALL TRIPS START AND
END ON A LOCAL STREET. TRAFFIC
SIGNAL MAINTENANCE STREET
LIGHTS POWER BILLS FOR NINETEEN
THOUSAND STREET LIGHTS THAT
TYPE OF THING BASICALLY
UTILIZED ALL OF OUR AVAILABLE.
THERE WAS REALLY NO FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR PLANNED
RESURFACING OR SIDEWALK WORK.
SO THIS IS WHY SB ONE IN AND
SPECIFICALLY MY POINT IS
BECAUSE SB ONE O'CLOCK AND
BOOKED UP THE ROAD MAINTENANCE
AND REHABILITATION COUNTY MRP
FUN THE CODE CITIES AND
COUNTIES- IS TO CREATE- AS A
MATTER OF INFUSION. HELLO
THANKS TO SB EVERY CITIES TRêN
BUDGET ESSENTIALLY ACROSS THE
STATE AS WE GRAPPLE WITH A
FUNDING SHORTFALL THAT WE
ESTIMATED BE APPROXIMATELY
SEVENTY BILLION DOLLARS. SO
ACCORDING TO OUR LOCAL STREETS
AND ROADS- FROM. NEEDS
ASSESSMENT. THAT WE CONDUCT
EVERY YEAR SB ONE SHRINK THE
FUNDING SHORTFALL BY BUT
EIGHTEEN BILLION DOLLARS OVER
THE OVER THE TIMES OF THE OF
THE TEN YEAR PRO. INDUSTRY IT'S
CLEAR THAT IT'S AN IMPORTANT
PART OF. FUNDING PUZZLE IT'S
NOT THE ONLY PIECE AND IT ALONE
WILL NOT SOLVE ALL OUR PROBLEMS
ARE ADDRESS HOLD NEEDS
INFRASTRUCTURE MAINTENANCE.
YOU'RE WELL AWARE SIX. EVEN
WITH SP ONE THE AVERAGE
PAVEMENT CONDITION INDEX
STATEWIDE FOR CITIES IS
EXPECTED TO REMAIN AT
APPROXIMATELY THE SIXTY FIVE
OUT OF A HUNDRED RANGE THAT
IT'S BEEN FOR SOME SOMETIME.
THE REAL- IT. CITY IT IT IS IT
LESSONS OR ELIMINATES THE
DETERIORATION OF AN WHICH WAS
TAPPING FOR NUMBER. INSTEAD OF
STOCKTON SB ONE IS TO MAKE AN
IMPACT- IN THE FISCAL YEAR
NINETEEN TWENTY WE EXPECT TO
RECEIVE ABOUT FIVE POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS. AND IN NINE IN
NINETEEN TWENTY RE FOUR POINT
NINE MILLION. AND UTILIZING THE
NINETEEN. WE DELIVERED ONE AND
A HALF MILLION DOLLARS OF LOCAL
ROAD RESURFACING AND THAT'S
PRIMARILY PEEP AND PRESERVATION
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS- SLURRY
SHIELD A MICRO SERVICING WERE
ABLE TO RESURFACE TWENTY MILES
PAVEMENT. ROAD NETWORK OF SEVEN
HUNDRED IF YOU CAN'T ACT. WELL
THE PRODUCT OF ONE AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS FOR- WILL SIDE
WHAT. REPAIRS THAT ALLOWED US
TO MAKE REPAIRS THAT HUNDRED
NAY LOCATIONS INSTALL THIRD
BAKER BROWN'S- AND WE ALSO
UTILIZE THE FUNDING FOR OTHER
SMALLER PROJECTS SUCH REPAIRING
STREETLIGHTS THAT HAD BEEN
SEVERELY DAMAGED AND- CUTTING
CUTTING IN CORPORATE SIDEWALK
REPLACEMENTS ABOUT FOUR EIGHT
FIFTY OKAY. TO A- TERM
DISPLACEMENT.PROJECTS USING
NINETEEN TWENTY FUNDS WILL BE
MULTI MILLION DOLLAR PROJECTS
FOR ST RESURFACING MICRO
SERVICING AND SERVICIOS
PRIMARILY AND SIDEWALK REPAIRS.
AS WELL AS SEVERAL PROJECTS TO
REPAIR APARTMENTS AT SOME OF
OUR- THE BRIDGES WHERE WHERE WE
HAD SOME SORT UNDERTAKEN AND
THEY'RE SERIOUS STRUCTURAL
CONCERNS. BUT YOU CAN SEE FOR
STOCKTON OUR USE OF THE ARM OR
A SB ONE MONEY IS ALL ABOUT
PAYMENT PRESERVATION ASIDE
REPAIRS TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS
THAT LOCAL. RESIDENTS REALLY
ARE ABOUT. TERMINATION THE
PRICE WE'LL MAKE OUR STREETS
SAFER LESS CONGESTED BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY WILL KEEP OUR
NETWORK IN A GOOD STATE OF
REPAIR WHICH IS WHAT. CITIZENS
CARE ABOUT THE PROJECTS WOULD
SIMPLY NOT EXIST WITHOUT SP
ONE. THEIR EVIDENCE THAT THE
FUNDS ARE BEING USED FOR THEIR
INTENDED PURPOSES INCREASED.
REPAIR WORK ON CITY ROADWAYS
AND CSP COMMAND. IS VISIBLE
MEASURABLE AND UNDENIABLE. THE
FUTURE FOR STOP OR ANY OTHER
CITY IN THE STATE THE MASSIVE
BACKLOG OF BASIC MAINTENANCE
WORK IT WILL BE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE. CAN KIDS
SO WE- THE NEED ROAD WORK. SB
ONE WAS A LANDMARK
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL THE TOOK A
MAJORITY OF LET'S SUPERMAJORITY
LEGISLATURE TO PASS AND THE
WILL OF THE VOTERS AS YOUR
WHERE ENSURING ASP AND FUNDS
ARE NOT OR EVER A- THIS IS
CHRIS ROADWAYS AND MAKE A
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM SAFER
MORE EFFICIENT AND ULTIMATELY
SUSCEPTIBLE SO I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK. THE CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TOM CONTINUED **** ON
THIS ISSUE THANK YOU ARE
RUNNING. FOR THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON-
CHAIR- NUMBER THE COMMITTEE-
RUN PRETTY GOOD HERE ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES ON THE
LEASE TRANSPORTATION UNTIL IT
IS LAW YES AND I'M ALSO HERE
HEY FOR BIGGER UNFORTUNATELY
MAKING BECAUSE FLIGHT WAS
CANCELED THE- TRONG MAN
ONTARIO- AND THAT FLIGHT WAS
CANCELED SO- APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE AND
PRESENT YOU TODAY. OR AGAIN.
PARKS FROM ACCORDING TO CAVE
STOCKTON. THE IT SHOULD BE
NOTED THAT CITIES AND COUNTIES
ARE. FOR MORE THAN 80% OF
CALIFORNIANS ROAD WORK- AND ARE
AS GOING TO MENTION- WHERE
EVERY TRIP- BEGINS AND ENDS- IN
THIS STATE- FUNNY SHORTFALL-
GORDON REALLY BOILS DOWN TO
ONGOING FUNDING TO EXIT.
BEATING THIRTY OR FOR PAYMENTS
AT BILLION DOLLARS FOR SUCH
COMPONENTS AND TWO AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS FOR BRIDGES-
OVER THE NEXT. EIGHT TO TEN
YEARS- AND THAT'S WITH SB ONE.
WELL PAYMENT AND BRIDGE WE NEED
THAT FUNDING NEEDS ARE ARE
FAIRLY STRAIGHTFORWARD TO THINK
ABOUT- IT'S EASY YOU ARE FOR
THE GENERAL PUBLIC TO FORGET
ALL THE ADDITIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT'S TIED
INTO OUR ROAD SYSTEM WHICH WE
CALL CENTER COMPONENTS- THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR CITY
STREETS- THAT INCLUDE CURB
RAMPS SIDEWALK STORM DRAINS-
STREETLIGHTS TRAFFIC SIGNALS-
AND SIDEWALKS- I MET I WATCHED
READY UP NOT NOT TO MENTION
DEDICATED BY. THANKS I'M- A
GIRL. ENTER TRANSPORTATION UP.
OUR NEXT LOOK AT YOU THE ROAD I
NEED TO SAYS WILL BE TAKING A
CLOSER LOOK AT THE GROWING
FUNDING NEEDS FOR THESE TYPES
OF THE CENTER COMPONENTS AND
BRIDGES- LOCAL AGENCIES
CALIFORNIA OWN OVER TWELVE
THOUSAND BRIDGES- WE KNOW THAT
EIGHT HUNDRED TWENTY NINE- OF
THESE BRIDGES NEED TO BE
REPLACED BY ANOTHER THING OVER
EIGHT HUNDRED. M. WE- WARREN
CAN BE HERE TODAY HE DID SHARE
WITH ME HOW SB ONE HAS HELPED
THE CITY POMONA SO FOR SB ONE
ALLOCATION TO HELP PROMOTE A
COMPLETE THE FOLLOWING
PROJECTS- REPAIRING OF THIRTEEN
STREET FOR TWO POINT THREE
CENTER LANE MILES- WITH THE
SEVEN. THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT
THEY RECEIVED IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN- AND
THE RE PAVING OF SIXTEEN
STREETS OR FOR CENTER LINE
MILES WITH THE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS. ONE FINE THAT
CV. SERVICE THIS CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR THERE HAVING EIGHTEEN
STREETS. OR FOR POINT THREE-
CERTAINLY MILES WITH THE TWO
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS-
THEY'RE SET TO RECEIVE- FROM SB
ONE IN THE CURRENT FISCAL YEAR.
ARE THE CITY FROM ON ALL THAT'S
THAT SB ONE WILL HELP DELIVER-
ON SOME OF THE FOLLOWING
PROJECTS AS WELL- FOR EXAMPLE
THE POMONA MULTI NEIGHBORHOOD
PEDESTRIAN BICYCLE IMPROVEMENTS
PROJECT. I'M DOUBLE DESIGNING
CONSTRUCT BICYCLE AND
PEDESTRIAN IMPROVEMENTS. ON
LARK ON NINE LARGE STREET
SEGMENTS AND IN FIFTEEN
INTERSECTIONS THROUGHOUT THE
CITY- THIS PROJECT IS ENTIRELY
FUNDED WITH THE NINE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS- BACK TO
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM CYCLE
FOR. FORTY I IN TWENTY NINETEEN
AND THAT'S A AS YOU KNOW IN SB
ONE- FUNDED PROGRAM- ALSO THE
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS- CALTRANS STATE ROUTE
SEVENTY ONE- WIDENING PROJECT
PARTIALLY FUNDED WITH FORTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS SB ONE
STREET COURT AND HAS BEEN
PROGRAM WILL BEGIN THIS FALL
FOR HOMEOWNER THIS IS A NOTE
FOR DO PROJECT WHITE IN THE
REMAINING- THE REMAINING AUS.
OF THE- OUR FROM GLAZER BLANKS
THAT EACH DIRECT FOR YEARS THIS
STRETCH OF HIGHWAY BEEN CHAO
WITH A TRAFFIC CONGESTION-
FORCING DRIVERS USE POMONA'S-
STREETS TO AVOID THE
CONGESTION- WHICH CAUSES
ADDITIONAL WEAR AND TEAR- TO
THE LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS
NETWORK. FINALLY THE GOAL LINE
CONSTRUCTION AUTHORITY WAS
AWARDED NEARLY THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN- FROM THE TRANSIT AND
INTERCITY RAIL CAPITAL-
PROGRAM- THAT'S ANOTHER SB ONE
FUNDED PROGRAM- TO FILL THE-
FUNDING GAP TO EXTEND THE GOAL
LINE- INTO THE CITY OF PALM.
THAT'S A LOT WHICH IS A ONE IN
MILLION OUR PRODUCT- THE TO BE
CA. IN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND
THE CITY HOPES THAT IT WILL
SPUR MORE TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT- NEAR THE STATION-
WHICH THE CITY BELIEVES WILL
HELP- BENNETT- THE CITY'S
ECONOMY. AMONG ALSO BELIEVE
THAT THE COMBINATION OF THESE
PROJECTS WILL CONTINUE MAKE A
MEANINGFUL DIFFERENCE IN THEIR
ABILITY TO- PROACTIVELY ADDRESS
PAVEMENT MANAGEMENT- LOOKING AT
THEIR- CONDITION INDEX TRANSFER
TWENTY THIRTEEN TO TODAY- THEIR
NETWORK. THEIR PC WENT FROM.
WENT FROM SIXTH FLOOR FROM
SIXTY FIVE POINT THREE IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN TO SIXTY EIGHT
POINT ONE I'M AS OF LAST MONTH
WHEN IT WAS LAST MEASURED SO-
THREE POINT DIFFERENCE- IN A
SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME- AND- AND-
YOU KNOW. RIGOR OUR FROM CITY
POMONA- DID MANAGE TO ME THAT
THAT WAS MOSTLY RUBLE TO SB
WHAT FUNDS. YOU WANT. JUST TWO
AND A HALF MILLION DOLLAR. I TO
THIS MONESSEN THE ROAD MINUTES
RIVER PROGRAM STANDS AT ABOUT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY-
THANKS SB ONE. ALSO JUST WANTED
TO POINT OUT THAT THE LEGACY
SAQIB ALSO JOINED IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH SIX ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS- TO CREATE THE
CITY COUNTY PAVEMENT
IMPROVEMENTS CENTER OUR
PARTNERSHIP INCLUDES UC DAVIS
UC BERKELEY SELLS A STATE CAL
STATE LONG BEACH A CSU CHICO
CAL WELL. THE PURPOSE OF THE
TRAINERS TO MAKE LOCAL PAYMENT
NETWORKS LAST LONGER COST LESS-
AND ULTIMATELY BE MORE
SUSTAINABLE- THE- ALREADY
OFFERS TRAINING COURSES THAT
OFFER REAL WORLD BENEFITS TO
SITTING COUNTY ENGINEERS THAT
ARE IN THE FIELD- WILDS TOO
EARLY TO TELL WE HOPE THAT THE
CENTER- PROVIDES ANOTHER
STABILIZING FACTOR- TO THE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE ARE MAKING
IN OUR LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS
NETWORKS ESCORT. THE POOR FOR
THEIR IN FUNDS ARE FOR ALL
CITIES TO CARRY OUT THERE I
MEAN IT'S WORKS- THAT CITIES
ARE MAKING PROGRESS IN THIS
MASSIVE BACKLOG- AND THEY PLAN
TO KEEP THEIR PROMISES TO THE
RESIDENTS. AND THERE ARE TAX
DOLLARS FOR LONG OVERDUE
INVESTMENTS- IN OUR LOCAL LIVE
FOR STRUCTURE. I WANT TO THANK
CHAIRMAN BELL- FOR YOUR
CONTINUE LOOK I LEADERSHIP- ON
THESE ISSUES AS WELL AS THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE-
WITHOUT TALKING TO MY COMMENTS
BUTTE. FOR QUITE AFTER THE
CATTLE THANK YOU THANK YOU
WHAT. KEY THE DONE. REPRESENTS
SO HELP SO FEEL COUNTY SIR
COUNTIES THAT HAVE TAX
THEMSELVES- THROUGH SALES TAX
AND OTHER MEANS TO FUND VARIOUS
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS SO
KEYS. THE WELCOME THANK
CHAIRMAN BELL CENTRE GALGIANI
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HERE AS YOU VERY WELL
STATED ON BEHALF OF THE NOW
TWENTY FIVE SELF HELP COUNTY.
I'M THRILLED DECADE. OF DOING A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT HEAVY LIFTING
TO CALIFORNIA MOBILITY THREE IN
FIRST PROJECTS LARGE AND SMALL.
AS WELL VESTMENTS AND TRANSIT
OTHER REAL PROJECTS AS YOU KNOW
THESE JURISDICTIONS ARE WERE
HAS THE CHAIRMAN STATED THEY
VOTED BY A TWO THIRDS MAJORITY
TO TAX THEMSELVES TO IMPROVE
THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE. WE TAKE
THE TRUST OF ORDERS PLACED IN
THIS VERY SERIOUSLY I'M SURE
MOST YOU HEARD OF STATE
PROMISES MADE PROMISES KEPT AND
THAT'S MORE THAN JUST ARMADO
IT'S THE KEY TO OUR SUCCESS. I
SUGGEST THAT SB ONE HAS A
SIMILAR OBLIGATION TO THE
VOTERS A CALIFORNIA. TRUSTS AS
WE DO OUR PROJECTS WE DRINK WE
GAIN CREDIT. TRANSPORTATION
WORK FOR EVERY STE IN OUR STATE.
THE SELF HELP COUNTIES
EXISTENCE IS THE RESULT OF
CHRONIC UNDER INVESTMENT NOT
ONLY BY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BUT ALSO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
IT DIDN'T HAPPEN OVERNIGHT IT
TOOK PLACE OVER SEVERAL DECADES
AND IN THAT VOID LOCAL LEADERS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
STEPPED UP AND CITED THAT
YOU'RE COMMUNITIES NEEDED MORE
IN. TAX YOURSELVES TO FILL THAT
VOID THAT WAS LEFT BY. THE FED.
VERY PLEASED STATE DEPT UP WITH
SB ONE TO BE A FUNDING PARTNER
IT'S GOING TO TAKE DEBT. AS
MENTIONED EARLIER TO CONTINUE
TRYING TO BUILD OUR WAY OUT OF
THAT CHRONIC AND INVESTMENT THE
KEY IS GOING TO BE TO MAINTAIN
THE INTENT OF SB ONE AS WE DO
THAT. TO IMPROVE OUR ABILITY.
STATIONS I'VE HAD THE GOOD FOR
TUNE TO BEING IN THE ROLE THAT
I AM HERE TODAY IS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF SOFTBALL CANNONS
FROM MOST TEN YEARS. AND WE'VE
SEEN. A DOWN A TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING. NOTHING IN THE PAST
DECADE IN OUR SAVE THEM LONGER
THAN THAT. HOLD SUCH PROMISE
FOR TRANSPORTATION IS WHAT THIS
LEGISLATURE. THE LAST
LEGISLATURE DID IN.
ACCOMPLISHING SB ONE. AND WE'RE
GRATEFUL TO HAVE THE STATE
COMMUTING TO TRANSPORTATION
JUST AT OUR LOCAL. THIS IS HAVE.
SB ONE RESULTED IN A PHASE.
OVERHEAD SB WILL GENERATE
MONIES THAT HAVE RESULTED IN US
TO COMPLETE PHASES IN HIGHWAY
CONSTRUCTION TRANSIT AND
REGIONAL PRIORITY. OUT THAT A
PATIENT FROM THE STATE. SIDE
KNOWING THAT THERE'S A RELIABLE
SOURCE OF FUNDING THAT ALLOWS
TO FIX THOSE PROJECTS POTHOLES
LOCAL STREETS A MAJOR HIGHWAY
PROJECTS. WELCOME COLLECTIVELY
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO BE
INNOVATIVE WITH SUFFICIENT
PROJECT DELIVERY MAKE SURE THAT
WE MINIMIZE BLACKER SEES AND
NOT BUILD UPON THEM INNOVATIONS
IN PROJECT DELIVERY THAT WAS
MENTIONED ON THE FIRST PANELS
FAR DESIGN BUILD G. C. BUT-
TECHNOLOGY. MAN TO MAN
INCENTIVIZE BEHAVE. BUILDERS IN
C. EFFORTS TOWARD ADVANCE
MITIGATION ALL OPPORTUNITIES
WERE MAKES SENSE SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO LOCAL PROJECTS
SPONSORS. FOR THE RESPECT TO
THIS LEGISLATURE I DON'T THINK
THE LOCAL AGENCY SHOULD HAVE TO
COME HERE EVERY SINGLE TIME
LIKE TO YOU LATER BLY'S ONE OF
THE INNOVATIVE PROJECT DELIVERY
TOOLS. WE MENTIONED OF THE- IS
THAT CAL SAYS APPRECIATED IN
THE- ASSUMPTION OF DNIEPER
FORTY IT'S A GREAT TOOL WE HAD
TO COME TO THE LEGISLATURE ON
FOUR DIFFERENT OCCASIONS TO.
EXTEND THE SONS. AND THE FOURTH
AND FINAL TIME. BUT YOU'RE
RUNNING THE BILL EACH TIME. WE
TO DO A LOT OF SENSE AND
PROPOSED TO THE BODY THAT. THE
LOCAL AGENCY. HAVE GOVERNING
BOARD OFFICIALS. WHO ARE
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE VOTERS WHO
CAN MAKE THE PROJECT. FOR THEIR
PROJECT IN BE ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THOSE AND COME BACK AND REPORT
TO THE CDC CALTRANS FOR THIS
BODY ABOUT THE PROGRESS THAT.
BUT ASKING THEM EVERY TIME
BECOME FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
SEEK APPROVAL I THINK IS AN OUT
METHOD AND THAT WE SHOULD LOOK
TOWARDS THE FUTURE. POWERING TO
ACTIVELY. DECISIONS BOOKLET.
SPEND THE MONEY A- AND BE
ACCOUNTABLE NOT ONLY TO THEIR
LOCAL BORDERS IMPORTS BUT ALSO
HERE TO THIS BODY AND I THINK
THAT WE CAN WORK CONTENT TO.
MAKE IMPROVEMENTS. YEAH WE
SHOULD BE DELIVERING PROJECTS
AS QUICKLY AND EFFICIENTLY AS
WE CAN ADDRESS BE ONE. BY THE
CHAIRMAN SKINNER GALGIANI IN
YOUR COLLEAGUES WHO ARE ABLE TO
BE WITH US HERE TODAY FOR
CONTINUING TO PUSH FORWARD AND
TO IMPLEMENT THIS FUNDING. IN
THE MANNER THAT YOU-
CONSTITUTED SB ONE FOR THE
VOTERS AND AGAIN I'LL JUST SAY
THAT. THE BIGGEST PARTY THAT I
THINK THIS LEGISLATURE CAN DO
FOR YOUR VOTING IS TO KEEP THE.
THE ONE IS THE DELIVER MONEY.
TO THE CITIZENS OF CAL TO
IMPROVE OUR MOBILE IN
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR ALL AND WITH THAT I'D TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS AT THE END BUT
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO IN OUR OUR LOW SPEAKER IS
JIM LAWSON FROM REPRESENTS THE
LOCAL TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITIES AND- IS THE CHIEF
EXTERNAL AFFAIRS DIRECTOR OF
SANTA CLARA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITIES
WELCOME JIM. MISTER CHAIRMAN HA
APPRECIATE THE IN. AND AS THE
CHAIR IS WELL AWARE THAT SANTA
CLARA WAS THE FIRST SELF HELP
COUNTY. LARGE PART DUE TO HIS
EFFORTS. AND I WOULD ALSO.
GUILTY I MEAN I HAVE THAT
MEASURE TO SEE YOU I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING ON THE A
SUPPORT OF DRUG USE. IN THE
NINETIES SO PRETTY WITH CENTER.
THE BILL THAT. THAT'S RIGHT.
PART ME SIR SO BY INVESTING
THAN FIFTY TWO BILLION DOLLARS
OVER TEN YEARS AND CALIFORNIA'S
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
INCLUDING MORE THAN NINE
BILLION IN NEW FUNDING FOR
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION SB ONE IS
BRINGING OUR TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK A STATE OF. WE'RE
INCREASING MARKET IT WOULD REST
WITH LOCK AND WE'RE MAKING
MEANINGFUL INVESTMENTS IN
PROJECTS THAT IMPROVE SAFETY
AND REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. IT'S NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE OVERSTATE HOW MANY
DIFFERENTSURFACE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS AND PROGRAMS ARE
IMPACTED BY SB ONE TODAY I HOPE
TO HIGHLIGHT SEVERAL OF THE
WAYS IN WHICH SB ONE IS
IMPROVED CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK. FIRST
SB ONE PROVIDES ROUGHLY THREE
HUNDRED MILLION ANNUALLY IN NEW
FUNDING TO THE STATE TRANSIT IS
SYSTEMS PROGRAM. THAT PROGRAM
THIS STA IS THE LIFEBLOOD OF
PUBLIC TRANSIT IN FUNDS AND
CAPITAL PURCHASES AS WELL AS
OPERATIONS. WITH SB ONE FUNDS
TRANSIT AGENCIES ACROSS ACROSS
THE STATE TO BEEN ABLE TO AVOID
SERVICE CUTS AND FARE INCREASES
IN SOME CASES WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO EXPAND SERVICE AND PROVIDE
PARKING TO DISCOUNTS TO TRANSIT
RIDERS. SB ONE ALSO PROVIDES
MORE THAN A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR STATE OF GOOD REPAIR
PROJECTS THAT IMPROVE SERVICE
BY ABILITY INCREASE SAFETY FOR
THE TRAVELING PUBLIC. THE ONE.
COUPLE FOR THE STATE'S
TRANSPORTATION INTERCITY RAIL
CAPITAL PROGRAM. WITH THAT
FUNDING CALIFORNIA'S STATE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES BEEN
ABLE TO ESTABLISH A MULTI YEAR
PROGRAM OF PROJECTS WILL
TRANSFORM HOW CALIFORNIANS
TRAVEL. THAT PROGRAM THOSE
PROGRAM OF PROJECTS APPROVED IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN INCLUDES.
SEVERAL OTHERS I DID WANT TO
JUST STOP AND MENTION HOW
IMPORTANT SENATOR IN U. POINTED
THIS OUT EARLIER. IT IS TO HAVE
MULTI YEAR FUNDING AGREEMENTS
FOR LARGE. US IN TRUCKS PROP.
APART BAY AREA RAPID DISTRICT
IS DEPLOYING RAIL CARS WHICH
WOULD THE ROE STOCK SOME OF THE
OLDEST IN THE NATION. THEY WILL
HAVE COMPLETION OF A- NATION
BASED TRAIN CONTROL SYSTEM
TOGETHER THESE IMPROVEMENTS
WILL ALLOW FOR AN INCREASE IN
TRAIN FREQUENCY AND LENGTH.
WHEN COMPLETE THE PROJECT WILL
EXPAND PARTS CAPACITY TO
ACCOMMODATE OVER WITH THAT.
WRITERS DAY. LA METROS
ADVANCEMENT OF NEW TRANSIT
CARTER'S BOLIDEN LIGHT RAIL
EXTENSION TO MONTCLAIR HE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY TRANSIT CARTER
WEST STAND LIGHT ALTERING CAR.
LINE LIKE REALLY INTO PRINCETON
ALL RED LIGHT LINE RAPID.
PROJECTS WERE MORE THAN A AND
TWENTY FIVE. ADDITIONAL RIGHT
DELAY MATTRESS. PER DAY. HERE
AT SAC RT R. LOOK PROVIDE.
EXPANSION OF SERVICE INCREASE
FREQUENCY ON VARIOUS LINES AS
WELL AS THE DEPLOYMENT OF NEW
LOW FLOOR RAIL VEHICLES
REPLACING THE EXISTING ORIGINAL
GOING STOCK. ANTELOPE VALLEY
TRANSIT AUTHORITY IS DEPLOYING
SEVEN NEWS ZERO EMISSION BUSES
AND UPGRADES TO CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE THIS WILL BRING
THE ENTIRE ANTELOPE VALLEY ST.
UP TO ZERO EMISSIONS IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY PTA HAS BEEN
AWARDED A TOTAL OF SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. THROUGH THE TI RCP FOR
A PART EXTENSION TO SILICON
VALLEY TO APPROXIMATELY 60% OF
THE FUNDING FOR THE T. I. R. E.
IS COMING FROM SB ONE.
ADDITIONAL. OBVIOUSLY BRENT IN
THE CAP ORDER JOINT OUR A
THIRTY. HAVE RECEIVED SICK AND
FROM SB SUPPORT. D. I. R. C.
CALTRAIN WILL RECEIVE A TOTAL
OF A HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE
MILLION TWENTY ELECTRIFICATION
OF THEIR VEHICLEFLEET. SIMILAR
MULTI YEAR FUNDING IT. THE
CAPITAL JPA RECEIVE EIGHTY MAY.
SINCE THE CARTER. TOGETHER THE
FULL PROGRAM A TWENTY EIGHT
PROJECTS WILL REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS BY ROUGHLY THIRTY
TWO MILLION METRIC TONS
COARSEST BE ONE PROVIDES MORE
THAN JUST INCREASE FUNDING FOR
THE SDA PROGRAM THE A. T. R. C.
P. WHAT DOES THE BILL A COP. IS
A PROVIDE TO THE COURT APPLES
FROM. IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS IS
ALLOCATED BY FORMULA ANNUALLY
TO THE CITIES IN OUR COUNTY THE
TWENTY ONE MILLION THE COUNTY
OF SANTA CLARA FOR THE
MAINTENANCE OF LOCAL ROADS
OTHER INCREASES IN FORMULA FUND
INCLUDE ALMOST EIGHTEEN MAY
STATE TRANSIT PROGRAM FUNDS
THINK IT OVER TO YOU FOR STATE
PREPARE FOR FROM THE MID LIFE
FOR ALL. OUTRIGHT TRACK AND
SALUTE THE RIBBON. PART PROGRAM
FOR. OUR RIDGE TO PART WHICH
CONNECT LIGHT WE ALSO WILL
RECEIVE APPROXIMATELY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS- IN JUNE FROM
THIS FROM THIS PROJECT THAT'S A
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR PRIZE. ASSISTANCE IS
GIVE YOU THE COMMUTER RAIL OF
CALTRAIN FOR A MILLION DOLLARS
FOR VEHICLE REHABILITATION
MILLION DOLLARS FOR TWO NEW
SIGNAL HOUSES NEAR PERTON
AVENUE AND FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND FOR BIKE PARKING
PROGRAM. LAKE REALIST THE CITY
RIGHT IN A QUARTER MILLION
DOLLAR FOR THE SAFETY SECURITY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR UPGRADE
THE PASSENGER INFORMATION
SYSTEMS AND EIGHT MILLION FOR
PRE CONSTRUCTION ENVIRONMENTAL
AND DESIGN WORK. THE PROGRAMS
THE SOLUTIONS TO CARTER'S
THERE'S THIRTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR EXPRESS LANES IN
MOUNTAIN VIEW IN PALO ALTO PART
OF THE U. S. ONE ONE MANAGED
PROJECT THAT WILL CONVERT THE
THING TO BE LANE ONE OF ONE.
FOR TWO THIRTY SEVEN TO SAN
MATEO COUNTY THE US ONE EIGHTY
FIVE CARPOOL TO CARPOOL TO
WRITE IT IS TO EXPRESS LANES.
THE THIRTY SEVEN STATE ROUTE
EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY EIGHT AND SAN
MATTEO SUBMIT A JOINT
APPLICATION. WITH EMPTY CAL.
REST FUNDS FOR A TOTAL OF TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS. FUNDS THE
CONSTRUCTION OF EXPRESS LANES
STUDENTS WANT ONE MISTER
CHAIRMAN I. FIFTY THREE I HAVE
A QUICK QUESTION AND I. HAVE
THAT I HAVE ANOTHER COMMITTEE
AFTER THE YOU NEED TO BE AT
WHAT I LIKE I'VE BEEN IN
AWHILE. IN BETWEEN MEETINGS AT
MY OFFICE. MR THE FOR THANK TO
UP I KNOW OF BE REPRESENT THE
FIRST IS DISTRICT WHICH IS VERY
WERE WIDE OPEN I HAVE SOME SELF
HELP VERY LITTLE- IN IN OUR
AREA BUT SO AND I WAS ON THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR
SIXTEEN YEARS AND WAS PART OF A
FOR TAKING WE DIDN'T LOG SO WE-
ASK. IS THAT WE TALK ABOUT AT
I'M HERE IS. PART OF MONEY ON
TOP ALREADY TACK GAL. OF FUEL
THAT WENT IN OUR ROADS SO MY
QUESTION IS THAT SO WE HAVE- I
I'VE BEEN LISTENING AND TRYING
TO FOLLOW ALONG MOST THE
PROJECT ARE IN. POPULATED HERE
AS I KNOW I'M OUT IN WHAT WE
SHOP SHOP PROJECTS- THAT ARE
ONGOING IN THE- THEY QUALIFY I
THE WEATHER SAFETY THERE'S BEEN
SO MANY ACCIDENTS OR DEATHS
RATCHET THOSE UP FOR THE A GOOD
PART OF THE SENATE TREAT THERE
ARE THERE ARE THERE
TRANSPORTATION TRANSPORTATION
ARTERIES- FREIGHT AND- TYPE OF
THINGS THAT COME THROUGH OUR
DISTRICT. EITHER ALL THE WAY TO
DIFFERENCES- AIR UP THE PORTS
TO THE MIDDLE OF THE COUNTRY-
ALSO UP TO THE PACIFIC
NORTHWEST SO MY QUESTION IS. SB
ONE DEFINED ONLY CERTAIN THINGS
THAT THE MONEY COULD BE SPENT
ON LIKE WEEK WE COULD WE COULD
DO A DIFFERENT MODES BUT WE
COULDN'T PLAY WIDEN ROADS OR OR
DO SO AT THE REGIONAL POTS OF
MONEY THAT CAME IN SO THERE
SHOULD BE POTS THERE SHOULD BE
THE POP THAT. THE WOMAN IS. AND
THEN THE- BILL. TAX BASE. TO
COVER THE TACK WE WANT TO SEE
FIT BACHARACH. I WOULD DEFER TO
OUR BUT I THINK WHAT WE WANT IS
PROBABLY A LITTLE TOO BROAD.
WELL MY POINT IS MAYBE A LITTLE
BROAD BUT MY WHAT I'M GETTING
AT HERE IS THAT I'VE I'VE HEARD
A LOT OF TALK ABOUT WHAT SB ONE
ALLOWS US TO DO BUT I'VE NOT
HEARD ABOUT THE OTHER PARTS OF
IT WERE FUNDS THAT WERE
ACTUALLY THERE BEFORE. BECAUSE
THEY'RE MORE BROAD SO FOR ME I
WANT TO LOOK AT THE ABILITY
THIS IS MIKE WHAT I'M TRYING TO
GET AT IS THAT. SOME UNLIMITED.
I THINK ON SB ONE. ART IS
HELPFUL US AS THE OTHER PARTS
WERE IN IF WE MARRY THOSE
TOGETHER TAKE THE POT OF SB ONE
AND MEET THE DEMANDS THAT IT
ARE THE GUIDELINES WITHIN AND
THE TAKE THE OTHER PARTS. AND
BE ABLE TO BACKFILL TO HELP.
MAKE THE PROJECTS YOU BETTER.
OKAY THERE WERE SOME. I HAVE A
CHART IN MY OFFICE. SO THE
SHOWS THE TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING IN CALIFORNIA. IT IT'S
ABOUT FOUR FEET WIDE BY ABOUT
FIVE FEET LONG. URGED BUT- BUT
A SEPARATE I CAN SIMPLIFY IT
THERE THERE'S- LOCAL GAS TAX
FROM THE STATE AND THEN THERE'S
A FEDERAL GAS TAX THAT'S BEEN
HISTORICAL WE GET. ONE POT
MONEY WE ALSO GET DIESEL FUEL
TAXES WE GET TO A- REVENUE FROM
MAYBE SOME OTHER SOURCES THE
LOCAL SELF HELP COUNTIES THERE
POTS OF MONEY- OF. MONEY
COMBINED GOES INTO THE STATE
HIGHWAY COUNTY. THE COUNTY WANT
TO LOOK AT YOUR YOUR QUESTION
CHARLIE OF IS REGARDING STATE I
WOULD CAL STATE HIGHWAY ACCOUNT
ALLOCATED TO. GENERALLY THINGS
OF STILL UP PROJECTS THAT'S A
NEW ONE NEW PROJECT- WIDENING
OR AN INTERCHANGE OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT THEN YOU HAVE THE
SHOP. SHOP IS THE ROAD MAY KNOW
A ROAD REPAIRS AND THEN JUST RE
SERVICE SAYING KIND OF ROAD
MAINTENANCE KINDS OF ACTIVITIES
SO THOSE ARE THE- THOSE ARE THE
THREE. SOME MONEY NOW THE STEP
PROJECTS THE THERE'S BEEN LESS
AND LESS EACH YEAR OKAY THE
REASON WHY IS BECAUSE MORE AND
MORE HAD TO BE SPENT ON. THE
SHOP IN THE MAINTENANCE PART
BECAUSE THAT'S THE STATE
HIGHWAY NOW THE GAS TAX ALSO
GETS SUBVENTION. TO YOU WHEN
YOU WERE COUNTY SUPERVISOR GOES
BY A FORMULA. THE FORMULA GOES
TO THE COUNTIES AND THEN BY
FORMAL IT GOES TO THE CITIES
THE GAS TAX IS GOVERNED BY
ARTICLE NINETEEN OF THE
CONSTITUTION COULD ALWAYS BEEN
A ROAD ROAD TRIP FOR TATIAN A
REPAIR THERE'S- ARTICLE IN THE
STATE CONSTITUTION SO THE MONEY
WOULD GO TO. ZERO IN HIS GROUP
CORD IN RONI AND HIS GROUP IN
TERMS OF THE ANNUAL BUDGETS DAD
DAY WOULD ADOPT EVERY YEAR AND
YOU WILL ALLOCATED BASED ON.
WHAT YOUR NEEDS ARE SO THAT'S-
THAT'S THOSE ARE THE TWO PARTS
OF THAT'S WHERE THE GAS TAX
GOES SO WHAT PART OF THE GASKET
CLOSE TO THE STATE. AND PART OF
THE BIGGEST AS GOES TO COUNTIES
IN A PART OF THE GA TAX GOES
TO CITIES AND TOWNS. ALL RIGHT
WELL A PERSON THAT I. SAT
THROUGH THIS STEP PROCESS IS
YOU KNOW LOBBY NO PARTY TO IT
PAST PRISON MUST LIVE TO GET
WHAT I'M TRYING TO GET DONE BUT
MY POINT IS. I WANT TO TIE THIS
IS SOMETHING WE HAVE SB ONE
WHICH IS AYE AYE MORE NARROW.
AS FAR AS IS. ME FIXING REAP
ROADS AND WE HAVE. THE OTHER
PARTS OF MONEY IN THE WE HAVE
SELF HELP WE HAVE ALL THESE
OTHER PARTS. WERE THREE MILLION
HOME SHORT IN CALIFORNIA. AND
WHAT DO WE HAVE IN MY COUNTY
YEP TO LEVY TAXES OR TALK ABOUT
LEFT INTACT THE BILL THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO PUT THE HOMES
IT. MY QUESTION IS TRY TO
FIGURE OUT THE OTHER. THAT NOT
NOT AS RESTRICTED AS SB ONE
FUNDS. I WANT TO KIND OF FIGURE
OUT IF THERE'S A WAY WE CAN
MAKE AN AXIS SO I CAN GET SOME
HELP TO MY COMMUNITY SO THEY
CAN PUT THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
WE NEED. TO ALLEVIATE THE
CONGESTION SO WE CAN BUILD
HOUSES THAT'S REALLY WERE I
THINK THIS TIES TOGETHER AND IN
MY COMMUNITIES. WE DON'T HAVE
MASS TRANSIT AND WE WERE NEVER
GOING TO HAVE IT ALL RIGHT WE
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY LIKE SB
FIFTY WHICH FAILED. IF WE CAN
GET THERE. IN WHICH WOULD MAKE
SENSE TO ME RIGHT FOR GOING TO
HOUSING WE SHOULD PUT IT BY
WHERE WE HAVE TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AND- JOBS. SO I
GUESS MY POINT IS I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THE MONEY. GAME AND-
FIGURE OUT WHICH POTS I NEED TO
GO AFTER TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN SO
THAT'S WHAT MY QUESTION WAS I
KNOW THAT- LIKE YOU MISTER DON.
DOES SELF HELP COUNTIES AND YOU
KNOW MY COUNTIES ARE BEING. OUT
THEY WE ALL PAY INTO THESE. WE
ALL PAY TAXES WHO USE THESE
SYSTEMS. I MEAN. I KNOW ABOUT
THAT. THIS IS A GALLON FOR FUEL
I'M A TRUCKING BUSINESS I
UNDERSTAND IT. CHECK THE ROADS
WE HAVE A BILLION DOLLARS. IN
THE. I CAN'T THINK OF IT THE
HEAVY WEIGHT USE TAX THAT'S NOT
GOING INTO THE TO HIGHWAYS IT'S
STILL GOING TO BE IN GENERAL
FUND RIGHT WHICH IS WRONG UP ON.
ONCE OKAY BRITISH BONDS ALL
RIGHT WELL. ANYWAY MY QUESTION
IS I'D LIKE TO FIND OTHER
SPONSORS SO WE CAN POLITICALLY
FIX SOME OF THESE. SOME OF
THESE CONGESTION ISSUES WE HAVE
ALONG WITH NOT ADDING MORE DEBT
AND TAXES ON TO MY LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE IN THOSE
AREAS WHERE THEY HAVE MASS
TRANSIT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FOR INDULGING ME I'LL
COME AND LOOK AT YOUR MAP IS
FOUR FEET WIDE AND MAYBE WE CAN
FIGURE OUT WHERE A SLICE THAT
MONEY SHOULD GO. WELL THE RURAL
COUNTIES. MAYBE VIEW YOU CAN
COMMENT ON THIS THE REAL
COUNTIES GET A LANE MILE
ALLOCATION RIGHT TO GET. BASED
ON- BASED BY REGISTRATION A
CARS AND LANE MILES AND-
SURFACED ON SERVICE I GO THAT'S
THAT'S IT ALL. RIGHT IF. AND I
DON'T WANT YOU TO WALK WITH THE
SP ONE MONEY THE STRICTLY
SAVANNAH DOWN THE TO THE CITIES
AND COUNTIES HAVE VERY FEW
RESTRICTIONS. FIX IT FIRST I
MEAN WE'RE WE'RE SO FAR BEHIND
IN REPAIRS. THAT WE- WE
COULDN'T GET ENOUGH REGARDLESS
I EXPLAIN THAT EARLIER ABOUT
HOW MUCH WITH DOUBLE THE MONEY.
THEY WERE STILL. MAKE IT AN END
TO END OF THE ROAD. I DON'T
DISAGREE WITH YOUR YOUR PREMISE
TRYING TO MAKE IT. ALL THE
MONEY MORE CUSTOM. WORD RAISE
IT'S NOT. THE PLEDGE TO WORK.
FORTUNATELY NO ONE OF THE THAT
I GET A GET A GRAY STATE STATE
HIGHWAY TO GO THE TURN OFF ONTO
A- THE- LOCALS A ROAD YOU CAN
DO WE GO. I MEAN I DRIVE ON
THOSE ROW I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING IS A- AND BUT- ONE. FOR
A VERY SMALL AMOUNT THESE OUT A
LITTLE BIT ANY GET MUCH OUT OF
IT IN MY OPINION. SO THEY WAIT
THANK YOU FOR INDULGING ME
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR- OKAY.
I A OF. QUESTION ABOUT SB ONE
IN TERMS OF. ARE THERE ANY
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO DO TO
IMPROVE SB ONE KEEP DOT
MENTIONED. THAT ONE ISSUE OTHER
OTHER THINGS REGARDING- THE
ABILITY TO FUND PROJECTS THAT
USE A- SHOULD SHOULD BE ENTERS
A REFORM. THAT WE NEED- IN WITH
US THE ONE. TWO FOUR. YEAH
SINCE YOU MENTION MY NAME I'LL
JUST REITERATE THE ABILITY TO
HAVE LOCAL AGENCIES TO DO YOU
KNOW COMING FROM THEM HAVE DULY
ELECTED BOARDS AND PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION ALTHOUGH WE CAN
DO TO REMOVE THE BUREAUCRACY
FROM DELIVERING THAT MONEY TO
THE LOCALS IS GOING TO HELP US-
YOU KNOW PUT THAT MONEY TO WORK
AND THEN AGAIN THERE'S A NUMBER
OF TRIED AND TRUE METHODS THAT
THE STATE HAS. BEEN WE HAVE A
LOCAL AUTHORITY BILL BUT NOT.
THEY'RE JUST SOME THINGS I
THINK WE GET OUT OF OUR OWN AND
WRECKING SAID WE HAVE
PROFESSIONALS IN THE LOCAL
LEVEL WHO NOT ONLY KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE DOING BUT ALSO VERY
QUALIFIED TO MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS AND ALSO WILLING TO
COME. REPORT TO YOU CDC AND
OTHERS ABOUT THE PRIOR TO THAT
I THINK THEY'LL GO A LONG WAY
OF. REMOVING SOME OF THE LADIES
AND USING THAT MONEY
EFFECTIVELY THANK YOU CURTAIN
YES I WOULD ADD FROM THE-
CITIES PERSPECTIVE THAT. THE
REPORTING OF THE OF THE
PROJECTS THAT'S DONE EVERY YEAR
I THINK IS A IS A REASONABLE
AND VIABLE METHOD OF TRACKING
WHAT'S DONE. AT THE CITY AND
COUNTY LEVEL FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY. THIS PROGRAM
WHAT WE'RE PRIMARILY CONCERNED
ABOUT IS. ANY FURTHER
RESTRICTIONS THAT WOULD DELAY
OR SOMEWHAT. CONTROL THE DID
DISTRIBUTION OF THE FUNDS- SO.
I WOULD SAY FROM FROM A FROM A
PRIMARY PERSPECTIVE THE WAY
IT'S SET UP RIGHT NOW WITH IT
WELL. IT'S CERTAINLY FROM THE
FROM THE- WOULD DELIVERING PRO
FOR CITIZENS IT'S OF AN X.
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. OKAY WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PALACE WE
HAVE ONE LAST SPEAKER- OF THE
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA
ORGANIZATION IS SO COALITION OF
BUSINESS LABOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OF. THE SUPPORT
TRANSPORTATION KIANA DINER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR IS HERE TO
SPEAK FOR US OF. AND WELCOME
KIANA FOR. BEING THE LAST
SPEAKER. THANK YOU. THEN YOU
HAVE THE FLOOR AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR. STAFF MEMBERS OF THE
AUDIENCE THAT ARE STILL HERE-
IN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE AT THIS
AFTERNOON TO REPRESENT THE
PARTITION INDUSTRIES EXPERIENCE
WITH SB ONE TO DATE- I THINK
THE SHORT STORY HEN ONE THAT
HAS ALREADY BEEN TOLD WITH THE
TESTIMONY PROVIDED THIS
AFTERNOON. IS THAT S. ONE IS
WORKING THE REBUILDING
CALIFORNIA DOT CA DOT GOV
WEBSITE THE STATE'S ONE STOP
SHOP FOR SB ONE INFORMATION HAS
NEARLY EIGHTY THOUSAND OBJECTS
THAT HAVE BEEN FUNDED BY SB ONE.
PROCESS THE CROSS STATE THERE
ARE MULTIPLE ALL THE PROGRAM.
AS A RESULT- CONTRACTORS ARE
VERY BUSY AND MAN HOURS ARE AT
HISTORIC HIGHS SO THE INDUSTRY
IS FEELING THE POSITIVE
BENEFITS OF SB ONE SHORTLY
AFTER ITS PASSAGE THE AMERICAN
ROAD AND TRANSPORTATION
BUILDERS ASSOCIATION CONDUCTED
AN ECONOMIC IMPACT ASSESSMENT
OF WHAT SB ONE WOULD. MEAN FOR
AT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
THE STUDY CONCLUDED THAT THE
BILL WOULD SUPPORT AT LEAST ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS ECONOMIC ACTIVITY. AND
BENEFITS TO CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS AND BUSINESSES- OVER
A TEN YEAR THAT'S IT WAS A TEN
YEAR STUDY PERIOD AND THAT
TRANSLATES OVER SIXTY EIGHT
THOUSAND JOBS A YEAR. AT SAID
THE INDUSTRY FOR TO CONTINUE
BEING THE CONTINUED OPPORTUNITY
AFFORDED BY SB ONE. AT IMPROVE
SAFETY MOBILITY OF OUR
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
AS WELL AS CREATE MIDDLE CLASS
JOBS AND ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY.
THE INDUSTRY IS ALSO COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE SB ONE
IS- IMPLEMENTED IN THE MOST
EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE WAY
POSSIBLE. AND THAT THE PUBLIC
IS AWARE OF THE BENEFITS OF SB
ONE ON THEIR EVERYDAY LIFE. ADD
TO THIS END- WHILE SB ONE
INCLUDE SIGNIFICANT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
MEASURES WHICH WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT AT LENGTH AFTERNOON WE
THINK THERE IS ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT AND THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE- STARTED TO WORK WITH.
SUGGESTED BILL PROPOSED THAT
WOULD INCREASE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY- ESSENTIALLY
WHAT WE'VE CONCLUDED AT IS A
TRANSPORTATION POLICY PERCENT I
KNOW WHERE ALL THE NUMBERS ARE
I CAN DO SOME RESEARCH AND
FIGURE OUT WHAT SB ONE IS
FUNDING. BUT FOR THE AVERAGE
PERSON- SOMEONE IN THE MEDIA.
THAT INFORMATION IS NOT AS
READILY AVAILABLE AS WE THINK
IT SHOULD BE. AT SO OUR IDEAS
THAT WE WOULD ASK THE STATE TO
USE EXISTING SB ONE DATA AND
PROD HIM FOR TEN YEARS EXISTING
WEBSITE. TO JUST PRIDE THAT
PROVIDE SOME MORE EASILY AND
EFFECTIVE A CUMULATIVE DATA ON
THE IMPACTS OF SB ONE AND-
ABOUT IS ONE SUGGESTION WE
WOULD. THAT MAKE THIS AFTERNOON
TO ENSURE THAT JUST THE
EVERYDAY PERSON WHO KNOWS
THEY'RE PICKING THIS TAX WHEN
THEY FILL UP AT THE PUMP IS
GETTING. INSTEAD THE BENEFIT
TANGIBLE. OF THAT TODAY WE ALSO
THINK CONTINUE ALL PROACTIVE IN
EASY TO UNDERSTAND EDUCATION
AND OUTREACH. IS CRITICAL IN
FACT I AM IN ORDER TO CONTINUE
TO EDUCATE. VOTERS AND
TAXPAYERS- SO FOR OUR PART THAT
ISN'T JUST SOMETHING THAT WE
WOULD RECOMMEND TO THE- TO THE
LEGISLATURE WE BELIEVE THE
INDUSTRY HAS A STAKE IN DOING.
THAT SORT OF EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH AS WELL. WE DEVELOPING
A SUITE OF EDUCATIONAL DOCKET
ON AT THE ONE INCLUDES A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY. TRICKS
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE DISTRICT
FACT SHEETS AT TOP S. ONE
FUNDED PROJECT EACH YEAR
LEGISLATIVE DISTRICTS AND WE
pEXACTLY WHAT SENATOR WAS ASKING
ABOUT. I THOUGHT IT MIGHT GET
TO SOME HIS QUESTION YEAH- WE
HOPE THAT WILL GIVE YOU THE
INFORMATION YOU NEED TO KNOW
THAT WHEN YOU GO BACK TO YOUR
DISTRICT YOU'RE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE THAT INFORMATION TO
YOUR RESIDENCE- IN WILL UNVEIL
THIS EFFORT IN EARLY TO MID
APRIL AND WE'LL SCHEDULE.
MEETINGS WITH EACH OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND TO GO
OVER THAT DISTRICT INFORMATION-
I'D LIKE TO FINISH BY JUST
SAYING THANK YOU I WAS A CAP ON
YOUR TRANSPORTATION FOUNDATION
FOR. THIS AT THIS MORNING
NHIáU SPOKE THEIR SENATOR.
AND YOU REMIND ME. OF THIS IF
THERE'S ONE A FEW YEARS AGO WE
WERE TESTIFYING FOR THE NEED OF
THE ONE- THE TWENTY SIX IN THE
CITY HE CUT BILLION. YEARS FROM
STATE. IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM.
USING COUNTIES COLLECTIVELY
FACING THE SAME SORT OF TO
THEIR WORKS BUT WHEN STAFF.
LIMITED AND WE'VE. BECAUSE OF
SB ONE WE ARE LOOKING AT A MUCH
BETTER FUTURE THANK YOU. SO OF
IN TERMS OF THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY IN HAVING MY
CONSTITUENTS AND OTHER
CONSTITUENTS FROM OTHER MEMBERS
SEE. WHAT SB ONE DOLLARS ARE
BEING USED FOR HOW HOW WHAT IS
THE VISION FOR THE- OF RATED
WEBSITE THE U. IN WHAT WHAT IT
WHAT KIND OF GOALS WITH THAT
OUT CAN YOU DESCRIBE THAT YEAH
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE I THINK
THERE ARE- SOME METRICS THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR A VARIETY
OF AUDIENCES OBVIOUSLY THE%
INTERACTIVE MAP HAS PUT OUT WAS
HELPFUL EACH LEGISLATOR CONCERT
I DISTRICT CAN STE BOB MODE BY
OWNER OF. YOU KNOW LET ME BE BY
SEN ASSEMBLY DOES. BUT POP YOU
IS A AN EXCEL FILE OF YOU KNOW
ANYWHERE FROM HANDS HANDFULS TO
HUNDREDS OF PROJECTS BY
DISTRICT DEPENDING ON WHERE
YOU'RE AT- IT DOESN'T GIVE- AN
ILLUSTRATION OF WHERE THE
PROJECT IT IN TERMS OF ITS
PROJECT COMPLETION. SO I THINK
CEMEX SAP HELPFUL ARE YOU KNOW
THE NUMBER OF PROJECTS IN THIS
IS CUMULATIVE RIGHT ACROSS ALL
SB ONE NOT JUST SIGH LOAD IN
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS. AT A PRICE
THAT HAVE BEEN PROGRAMMED THE
NUMBER PRODUCTS THAT BEEN BEEN
OKAY AND THE NUMBER. THAT HAVE
BEEN PUT OUT TO BID AND
CONTRACTS AWARD. SOME OF DETAIL
I'M HOW MANY PLAYERS OVERALL
HAVE BEEN EXPENDED AT RECEIVED
AND THEN EXPECT. US THE BILL
SOME OF THE STATE SIX I THINK
WHEN WE INTERACT WITH PEOPLE
ASK US AND WE CAN'T MESS
BILLION. HEARINGS AND WE- ARE
PUTTING TOGETHER. IN TERMS OF A
HAS LOW. CONTRACTORS IN
COMMUNITY WORKED ON THE WORK
FORCE ISSUE CAN YOU TALK ABOUT.
HELLO SB ONE CAN BE IMPLEMENTED
WITH THE WORK WHAT WE NEED TO
DO ON THE WORK FORCE SIDE OF
THINGS TEMPLEMAN SP ONE I WILL
BE HONEST I AM PROBABLY NOT THE
PERSON TO ANSWER THAT UP FOR
YOU I KNOW THERE IS A LOT OF
WORK GOING ON I UBER TEACHING
CALIFORNIA JUST. AT THE HELM OF
THE CONVERSATIONS BUT I WOULD
BE HAPPY TO GET SOME FOLKS IN
TOUCH ON THAT YEAH THE ONE PUT.
SOME I THINK. FIFTEEN MILLION A
YEAR. INTO OF. DEVELOPMENT
BOARD'S. TO GENERATE SO.
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS OTHER
KINDS OF PROGRAMS TO ENCOURAGE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY-
APPRENTICES TO HELP US BUILD
THE TRANSPORTATION WE'RE GONNA
NEED MORE WORKERS- I ALWAYS SAY
LIKE THE WORKERS TO COME FROM
CALIFORNIA NOT FROM TEXAS OR
SOMEPLACE. I WANT CALIFORNIA
GROCERY STORES TO BE HAVING SB
ONE WORKERS BUY GROCERIES THERE
RATHER THAN AN- EURO TENNESSEE
OR SOMEPLACE SO I TAKE IT
BENEFITS ARE A CON. IN
CALIFORNIA IF WEEK THE WORK
FORCE TRAINED AND DEVELOPED AND
SO PARTY SP ONE WAS IF NOT A
LARGE A LOT OF MONEY BUT WE
WANT TO ENCOURAGE THE WORK
FORCE AND- I HEARD THE BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT EXCITEMENT THAT-
WAS BEING DEVELOPED WITH. THE
CALTRANS DIRECTOR EARLIER I
JUST WANT TO SAY I THINK THE-
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY A GROSS
IS GOING TO BE VERY IMPORTANT
TO COMPLETE PROJECTS. SO WE
HAVE TO WORK WITH ALL OUR
CONTRACTORS OF ANYBODY IN THE
CONSTABLE INDUSTRY TO GROW THE
INDUSTRY TO COMPLETE- THE
PROJECTS ON TIME AND ON BUDGET.
SO I THINK THAT'S KIND OF FOR
ME ONE THING I WANT TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON ON GOING BASIS WITH
THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY. AB
AGREE I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK GOING ON SO LET ME GET
BACK TO MY FACE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF. THE UNABRIDGED THE
WORK OF TRAINED XIN OKAY. I WON
IF THERE'S ANY SPEAKERS ANYBODY
WANT ADDRESSES. OKAY THEN WE'RE
ADJOURNED THANK YOU.